Whoopsie, whoopsie-boopsie.
I said... I said...
Man...
I missed my joke.
Okay, hold on.
Redo, redo, redo, redo.
Okay.
That
was...
that was it.
But I don't think it worked so well the second time.
Goodwin?
You guys hate it!
You hate it!
I know!
You guys aren't booing at all!
You hate it.
I get it.
Okay?
You're not booing at all.
I get it.
This was a good joke.
Boo?
Boo for real?
Yay!
I was saying boo.
You guys like it!
And there it goes.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Hello everybody.
Welcome to Helldivers.
Today I will be playing with... with Matora, with Haruka, and...
And...
I just like a normal amount.
Probably.
But it'll be fine.
It'll be okay.
If you're wondering where are those funny people at...
I'll tell you.
I'm playing the tutorial first.
And people wanted to see a video.
But it starts as soon as I open the game.
So I was like, close the game.
So now I'm going to start the game.
Play.
That's why we've been on a black screen this whole time.
I hope it'll capture.
It'll capture, right?
Oh yes.
Oh no!
Can't, can't, can't, can't capture!
It's there, it's there.
Okay.
Super Earth Ministry of Truth.
Semp.
Super Earth.
Whoa.
Am I lagging?
A tiny bit.
Prosperity.
Liberty.
Hi there.
Oh my god, neighborhood.
Democracy.
Oh!
Democracy!
Our way of life.
Oh.
Hello.
Oh, we're a happy family.
Oh, oh, oh!
Sweet liberty!
No!
No, not the liberty!
Invasion.
Look familiar?
Oh my god, he's in grief.
Scenes like these are happening all over the galaxy right now.
He's in so much grief, he's hallucinating his family.
You could be next.
Me?
That is, unless you make the most important decision of your life.
What's that?
Shaved my head?
Prove to yourself that you have the strength and the courage to be free.
Oh, I'm free!
I'm free!
Join the Helldivers!
Become part of an elite peace-keeping force!
These suits are so sexy!
Yeah!
See exotic new life forms?
Oh my god, I love him!
And spread managed democracy throughout the galaxy.
Become a hero.
Become a legend.
What?
Wow, that should be me in that plane.
Become a Helldiver.
A Helldiver.
Mm-hmm!
That's us today, that's us four.
Sorry that I'm lagging a little bit.
I'm going to fix some settings once it lets me.
Top secret!
Age?
Oh my gosh!
That's...
Wait, oh, average age, maybe?
The game is too high quality.
I can't believe we're actually going to become Helldivers.
Oh my god, me and you, girlfriend.
Project Hellsink.
Liberating the galaxy.
Stomping bugs.
They're bugs.
Every kid's dream.
I'm...
What kind of psychopath kid are you?
Good luck out there.
Thank you.
I'll see you on the front lines.
Okay!
Earn your cake.
You're on your own from here, recruit.
Whoa!
Bye, Pequod!
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Oh, that's me!
Okay, hold on.
Let's see.
Display.
Not ultra quality.
Maybe just regular quality.
Let's see.
Frame rate limit.
Let's just...
Why won't it let me...
Oh, frame rate limit on.
Okay.
Let's do like 60.
I don't think...
I don't think anymore will do anything on...
On YouTube anyway.
Is the Vsync on?
Well, no.
Wait.
I can never remember.
Is it on?
Wait.
Oh, gosh.
I'm lagging still.
269.
Stop, you guys!
Stop!
Hmm.
Okay.
Vsync usually off.
Wait.
Off if you are lagging.
Okay.
Let's apply this.
Oh!
Would you look at that?
Already fixed.
Is there a motion blur or anything like that?
Oh, motion blur?
Oh.
Maybe we can take...
Turn it like a little bit on.
Like 50%.
Yeah.
Zero?
Okay.
Zero motion blur?
You sure?
Okay.
I'll turn it off.
Let's see how this works now.
Quickly as possible.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Good.
Thank you.
Oh, where do I go?
Tab to view the map.
I need to go that way?
Hold on.
Hold right-click while map is open.
Oh.
Oh, neat.
I got to get my cake.
Okay.
Welcome to hell diver training.
Your instructor is waiting for you up ahead.
Please proceed.
Uh, how do I do anything?
Hmmm.
See you on the other side.
See ya.
Huh!
Hup!
I'm General Brash!
Super Earth's oldest and most grizzled war hero.
And I'm not easy to impress.
Helldiver training is the toughest test in the galaxy.
But I can tell that doesn't scare you.
Impressive.
Now, enough jib jab.
The upcoming obstacles will take everything your exceptional physique can muster.
This is it.
The real deal.
Get to it, soldier.
Whoa!
Okay.
Let's see the crouch.
Easy.
Space.
Or sprint.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I'm earning this cape with flying colors.
Traverse obstacles.
Easy.
In all my years I've never...
Dent?
Danger?
Dive?
Okay.
Dive.
Alt?
Wait.
Alt.
Oh.
What did I just press?
Dive!
Hello?
Oh!
I was pressing X on accident.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Do I have to...
This is fine, everybody.
I dove...
Okay.
Hold on.
Dive here.
The aliens have guns?
Oh.
Battlefield Injury Simulator.
Battlefield Injury Simulator?
Beep boop.
Oh!
That's not a simulator.
I think... I think I'm actually dying.
Nice.
Oh.
Use this thing.
That's me!
I said that!
Freedom never sleeps!
You're about to encounter democracy's sworn enemy, recruit!
Alright.
Where am I at?
What?
Oh.
Um...
There it is.
The terminate.
The scourge of liberty.
Ewww.
Arm yourself and show that bug the true meaning of freedom.
Yeah!
Now, use the grenade to close up that bug hole.
Oh.
Okay.
Otherwise, they'll just keep coming.
Grenade!
Uh.
G to quick throw a grenade.
How do I throw?
Oh.
What a catapult of an arm!
On to the next section.
Okay.
Um.
No diving.
Look up in the sky, recruit.
Up there is a super destroyer.
And it's all powerful stratagems of yours to command.
Control?
Use the stratagem now to take care of those bugs.
Is it nearly combat?
Just make sure you take a few steps back.
Um.
To dial.
Oh.
Beep boop.
I see it up there.
And...
Fire.
Wait.
I think...
Did I throw it too far?
Uh.
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh.
Don't come here.
Easy.
Oh.
I
don't have enough.
Okay.
Beep beep boop.
One more.
To here.
Look it.
They're hungry.
Who am I to...
Who am I to blow these guys up?
They're just trying to live.
Right?
The will of democracy.
Oh.
For democracy.
That's why.
Next lesson.
Helldivers fight in squads.
Meet your new squad member.
I love cardboard man.
What a fine soldier.
Your brother in arms.
My brother.
A battle forged bond that could never be replaced.
Until now.
Here's your real lesson soldier.
Squad mates can and will perish tragically all the time.
Now.
No cardboard.
Use the reinforcement stratagem to have another helldiver take their place.
Oh.
What the?
Putting in the Konami code up in here.
Oh.
A ball.
Here.
Oh.
What?
Oh my god.
It's like he never left.
How do I know which one I'm selecting though?
This is the real deal.
It's just you.
The gun in your hands.
And two thousand megatons of explosives in close orbit.
That's it.
Wait.
Okay.
So.
How do I know which one I'm selecting?
Okay.
Wait.
Hard reload.
What's three?
Piece of advice.
Moving around makes it hard to aim.
For A-list accuracy.
I'm scared.
Stay still while you shoot.
Oh.
Stay still?
Do you want me to die?
Oh my god.
I'm gonna die.
Oh.
Wait.
How do I switch to the grenade?
Oh.
That's not a grenade.
There they go.
Oh, man.
Three?
Where's the...
Oh gee.
Uh oh.
Reload.
Oh g...
Oh, Omg.
I'm gonna...
Don't, don't...
Velazquez.
Jay.
A genius.
Can I keep going?
Let's go.
Watch out for falling...
Hellpots.
What's the big gun?
Active hitting.
You are literally title card.
Literally invincible.
Oh, uh... throw down...
Hello?
Where's my gun?
I did it wrong!
Oh, okay.
Well, it looked like it was kind of busy up in here, you know?
Okay, there.
Get me...
Wow...
Oh my god.
That's the stuff?
Now, use a resupply strategy to get yourself some more ammo.
Okay.
Uh, how do I know what I'm...
Oh, I see, I see.
So you put in the code for whichever one that you want.
So if I want to summon a person, I put in that up, up, down, down.
Hello?
Um, I'm gonna die here if you don't hurry.
The DDR codes?
Yeah.
Load up, soldier.
Because playtime's over.
You've reached your final test.
Oh no.
This is the real deal.
Get to it!
Okay.
I'm scared.
This area is in dire need of liberation from the Terminid Scourge.
Activate that terminal!
I'm activating.
I'm activated.
Oh.
DDR!
I'm going!
Liberation.
I've never seen that.
I've never seen such flawless terminal activation.
Thank you, sir.
Now, somewhere around here is the flag of Super Earth.
Super Earth.
Find it and plant it where all can see its democratic glory.
This?
That's the flag of Super Earth, recruit.
Yep.
Plant it in the designated area.
Here?
We own this place now.
Make sure you show it the proper respect.
Salute the...
Yeah!
Oh my
god.
Where are the babies?
Oh!
Why are you still alive?
More prosperity!
Oh.
We did it.
Already, you've advanced the cause of debauchery I've ever seen.
Oh my god.
You've proved your worth.
You're ready to don your cape.
That's me.
Oh.
Contract.
Wait.
I thought this was a wall of like...
Oh.
Superhero.
Best people.
Wait.
There's a contract?
Termination?
Hold on.
This agreement will be governed by the laws of Super Earth and shall be terminated in the event that the enlisted is mortally wounded such that medical attention shall not be physically or finan...
Finan...
Financially...
What do you mean?
My...
My health is not financially justifiable.
Justifiable.
Don't read this?
Don't read it?
They care about me.
They gave me a cape you guys.
There's more?
Wait.
There's...
There's actually more.
Oh.
Wait.
Okay.
It's kind of the same.
I'm gonna do like a slow walk.
Okay.
This is the slowest I can go I think.
Get me my cape.
Reading the contract is a vile...
Oh.
You are a hell diver.
You remind me of a younger me.
I wish I could jump.
... and vulnerable and seven feet tall.
You're finally ready for the realest deal of them all.
The Galactic War.
I'm ready.
Democracy.
Justice.
They're in your hands now.
General Brush over and out.
Over and out.
She crouching.
Is it a requirement?
Oh.
Is the environment to be seven feet tall, or...
How long do you think all these guys had to wait in these pods for?
They were like, God, I hope this guy finishes soon.
Mint Fright Dom Level 1 Cadet!
They're frozen, don't worry.
Just like my desert dinner.
Yippee!
Mars!
Of Destruction!
It's the best anime ever.
Name your super destroyer ship.
Let's see.
Oh no, you guys, what should we name it?
What should we name it?
Dream of Battle.
Let's see what else we got on here.
Democracy.
It's a big one.
It's a cool one.
I bet they're waiting on me, so I don't want to take so long.
Independence.
Iron!
Law, Liberty.
Patriotism!
Pride.
Science.
Oh my gosh, this is too much pressure.
This is too much pressure.
Judge of Judgment.
Fist of War.
Here.
Maybe I just...
Founding Father of War.
Wait, was there Patriot?
Patriot.
Panther.
Ombudsman?
Patriot?
Where is...
These are sons?
Patriot...
Someone said family, right?
Patriot of family values.
Patriot of...
Patriot of Patriotism.
That's even better.
I'm the Patriot of Patriotism.
The most patriotic you could ever get.
Patriot.
Of Patriotism.
It's written right there.
Oh my gosh, that was awesome.
Okay.
Oh!
There's even more, wow.
Congratulations on completing training, Helldiver.
Thank you.
You're in charge of this vessel now.
Me?
The democracy officer awaits you on the bridge.
Welcome to the Galactic War.
Thanks.
All right.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, these uniforms are so sexy though, right?
Look how cool we look.
Wow!
Nice.
Okay, guys.
I'm glad that we could warm up with you.
Or I could warm up with you guys because I...
I'm so nervous.
Oh!
I am so nervous to collab with Enya.
But we're gonna have fun, okay?
The lalilulelo of lalilulelo-ism.
I'm so nervous.
You get to meet Irohoshi today.
I know.
It's, you know, because I collabed with Haruka before.
A couple years ago actually.
I mean, well, I haven't streamed for a couple years, but we played Among Us together.
I believe it was Among Us.
And of course, Matara.
Mom's spaghetti!
That's me!
Oh god, my tummy hurts.
Okay, let me let them know that I'm ready.
I'm... I'm ready now!
We're all waiting.
Hello?
Hi!
You're huge!
I thought you were a bug!
I gotta shoot you!
Wait, hello?
Hello?
I can hear you back on your...
I think all my... hold on, all my settings are messed up because I moved my computer yesterday.
Give me one second.
You're messed up.
Hello!
Hania, she's fixing her...
Hi!
It's a nice weather, isn't it today?
It's good weather!
Hello?
Sorry, I disconnected.
It was really weird.
Are you okay?
Is everything okay with you?
Wait, why are you throwing up after you're talking to me?
You said you enjoyed the comics!
I enjoyed it too much!
Why are you throwing up?
Why are you throwing up, Dayo?
Hi, Haru.
Oh, did I join it?
Hi!
They're already arguing.
It's been forever!
Yay!
The only time we collabed is when you graduated, now you're back!
I was just saying that!
I was like, it's been a long time since I...
It's been three years!
I know!
Three years!
We were mutuals and everything.
We were too shy to talk to each other and now we're here.
Now we're here.
Yay!
Sorry, Mr. TooBuzz.
I tried many things.
I'll boot up the game.
I'm so happy to collab with you guys!
Thanks for having me!
Yeah!
I was so excited!
I'm eating an egg sandwich, so I hope you don't mind my food.
I had an egg sandwich!
Oh my god, they're the same person.
Is it from Tim Hortons?
No, I got it from a store.
They have an egg sandwich.
A store?
Yeah, they have an everything sandwich.
Hold on, let me turn you guys... you're all not very loud.
I think you're very loud for me.
I'm always very loud.
I had a collab and every streamer was like yelling in it.
And now I have all the quiet girls.
It's ironic considering I shot all the time, but you always seem to catch me when I just woke up.
Every time I collab with Haru, she just wakes up.
Good morning!
Ohayo!
Alright, I'm gonna open the game.
Min, do I have you at it?
Because you can jump off of me to get into the game.
Oh yes, I have you.
How do I jump off of you?
You're gonna open my name and then you're just gonna do a join game from there.
Okay.
It's pretty easy.
You can figure it out, my love.
Hi!
I believe in you.
Yeah!
I'm so excited!
Thank you for joining me.
Basically, we got... Henya and I are fairly new to the game.
Mint, this is gonna be your first time.
My first time.
But Haruka is a pro.
Yeah, she's a pro at gaming.
She is like... she'll be doing all the stuff.
She'll be explaining how to do stuff while the three of us will probably just run around yelling.
Yeah, Haruka carry dayo!
Haruka carry dayo!
Yay!
It's true.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this dayo.
I'm looking... I see you.
Yeah.
Wait.
Play... wait.
I click... wait.
Join.
Hold on.
I have to get in the game first.
Okay.
And then you can get in.
Have some patience, Mint.
I don't even see where I say to join.
You'll see it once I'm in the game and like... yeah.
Okay.
I'll try it now.
Ba ba ba.
Oh, join get... you're so smart.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
It's so humble.
Yippee.
Is there an in-game chat or...
Yeah, you can type.
But we're going to be in Discord and talking to one another.
Okay.
How... what would you say is your experience, Mint Fulton, with shooting games?
I'm really good.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Oh, Minto.
Yeah?
You want to... hold on.
I have food in my mouth.
If you want to turn off your microphone...
Oh.
Press escape.
Uh-huh.
Go to options.
Go to audio.
Uh-huh.
And there's voice chat.
Oh.
Because I think you have broadcast microphone so I could hear myself and you and everyone at the same time.
Oh, I'm sorry.
No, no, no.
Yeah, she had it.
Is that better?
It's okay, guys.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
She's new to streaming.
She hasn't...
I'm new to streaming.
Yeah.
She's new to streaming.
She's got to learn.
She's rusty, I should say.
I'm rusty.
She hasn't streamed in three years.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Be nice to me.
You know what?
Fuck you.
I love you.
There you go.
Oh, boy.
All right.
Now this is how you know we're friends.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Yay.
Friend.
We've been...
Technically, we've been friends for almost four years, if you really think about it.
Yeah.
That's kind of crazy.
Isn't that crazy?
That is kind of crazy.
Yeah.
Will you defend it?
Wow.
I still remember when you first debuted, you were this cute little ghosty ghost.
Stop.
Stop talking about me like that, Mom.
You're embarrassing me.
And now she's old.
I know you're old.
I still remember when you debuted as this model, too.
And I...
Oh, my God.
I was so emotional.
I was like, oh, my God.
There's my baby little mint.
Aw.
Ew.
We'll ramp it up if Mint is comfy.
Okay.
But basically, Mint, you have to fight either the bugs, my cousins, or you gotta fight the robots.
I say, at the start, the bugs are much easier, because the robots jump back at you.
Oh, yeah.
That's bad.
If you have any questions, please ask ahead.
Right?
This is one of those...
Do you get the weapons...
Are they...
Are the weapons OSP?
What's an OSP?
Are they...
Do you get them...
Do you bring them with you?
Or do you get them, like, there?
You bring them with you, but you have to summon them.
It's called strategy.
Ask us anything.
Honestly.
Feel free.
Okay.
We'll yap at you.
We'll teach you.
I'm gonna run around.
I'm gonna look at my cape.
It's really flowy.
I recommend sticking with the buddy.
I recommend you stick with Henya.
And I'll be with you guys often.
Is this Henya?
Henya?
No, that's not Henya.
That's our commander.
Oh, God.
Yeah, that's me, Henya Dayo.
She's talking to the wrong person.
I love it.
He's a big, muscular man.
Henya, you're so...
Your muscles are so big.
Your brain is so large.
Oh, yeah.
I have been working on Dayo.
Thank you.
Where do I go?
Do I go into a little...
Go to the help pod.
At the end of the ship, there's, like, a little pod and you go into it.
Oh, here.
My very own help pod.
Yeah.
So, basically, like, you choose...
What am I doing?
The person who started.
What am I here?
And then you here pick, like, your stuff.
As you gain more levels, you'll be able to have more stratagems and, you know, you have more of them.
Okay.
Do I just click anything?
For now, you'll have very few.
Oh.
What's this?
Yeah.
Just add anything and then play around with it.
See how you like it.
Okay.
Help pod.
Holy fuck.
Ooh.
Let's go this one.
Oh, I can't even...
Wow.
You guys look so cool.
Thank you.
I got it from eBay.
Oh, wow.
Ooh.
eBay.
I bought $500 on eBay.
What?
There's even eBay on Super Earth?
Yeah.
Always.
And then my mom confiscated my credit card.
Oh.
So I can't buy any more.
All right.
It's because you bought those Roblox.
I did.
Oh, the Roblox.
I don't know what it is, but I did buy it.
The Fortnite money.
Oh, this one.
Oh, wait.
Extra pod.
Wait, can I equip it?
Why won't it let me equip?
Yeah.
Usually you can...
I think if you press R, you'll be able to equip in the equipments.
Yeah.
This one.
Oh, wait.
How do I get it?
Oh, ready?
Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm ready.
I think.
Oh, don't worry.
You'll see.
As you get into the game, it's a lot at first to kind of...
But now the best part is coming, Min.
Are you ready?
Oh, yeah.
Wah, wah, wah, wah.
You know what's really funny?
What?
I have the comfiest music playing right now.
You have what?
You're doing what?
Yeah.
I have the comfiest music playing in my ears right now.
Are you listening to Shalalala?
Shalalala.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I should be singing Shalala.
Yay.
But the...
If anybody saw the Bishojo concert, it's the Hanya and Haruka duo song.
Shalalala.
Na, na, na, na.
Oh, and there's a fire, by the way.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh.
You have to...
Nice.
I'm alive.
There's a little jellyfish.
Do you know how to summon your items?
Control, right?
Yeah.
And then...
Which...
What is it?
You play DDR.
Is it resupply?
No.
Just kidding.
It's your weapon.
You have like a little gun that you can order.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just clicked the resupply.
Yep, yep.
Oh.
Wait.
Nice resupply.
Yep.
You have a machine gun, right?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Oh, you have a machine gun.
And then Tab is your...
Tab is your map.
Tab is open.
Yeah.
He opens up your map.
I'm gonna grab...
Oh, yeah.
Well, there's...
Oh!
So, basically, if you run out of ammo, we always like to get a resupply over here.
Okay.
Also, where is she?
F is punch.
F?
You bitch!
V is your...
What is it called?
Stim.
Oh.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then you have your gun number one.
Gun number two.
Two.
Also scroll wheel.
Yeah.
Oh, you can also scroll wheel it?
You got it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right?
You can scroll wheel the gun.
Oh, wait.
No.
You can't scroll wheel the gun.
I don't think so.
My bad.
Wrong game.
Can I pick these up?
Which ones?
Oh, see?
There's little bugs coming up.
So, these little guys right here.
I have no idea how to play this game.
After bugs.
After guys.
You got to shoot them.
It's been a while.
You see that orange thing on the ground?
That means it's a bug breach.
So, they're coming up to attack us.
Okay.
That red thing is I'm summoning...
Be careful.
Stay away from that.
Oh.
I'm fine.
Yeah.
So, you'll see.
You'll get there.
It's a lot of fruit.
Are we going to the orange thing?
Orange is the main mission.
Usually, Haru and I like to like run around and do random stuff.
Oh, nice.
So, you guys can go to the orange thing.
Oh.
Tab.
Okay.
I see it.
Tab.
I know it's a little stressful at first.
Feel free to ask anything.
That's why...
Yeah.
Okay.
What is a jellyfish?
It's so cute.
Yeah.
There's different planets which do different stuff.
Oh, we got super credits.
Nice.
Yeah.
I got us some.
I got you, bae.
Whoa.
Thank you.
Got you super credits.
Wow.
That's a rock.
The red...
If you look at the map, there's like big red kind of...
Yeah.
... stuff.
Those are outposts.
That's usually an enemy nest.
Yeah.
I blew up something and it exploded on me.
Good.
Oh, don't worry.
That's a...
That means it likes you.
... these weird little onion-looking...
Yeah.
Those things.
... nipply things.
They look like onions to me.
Yeah.
Nipply, nipply.
So, if you run into them, they create like this fog.
And I think they help with avoiding the bugs because bugs rely on...
Oh.
Oh, they actually help you?
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I'm getting them except...
The robots rely on sight.
Bugs do not.
Oh.
Yeah.
But also, I think it's like it slows the bugs down a little bit.
Doesn't it?
I do not know.
I think it slows you down.
I thought it slowed them down a little tiny bit.
I forget.
The big orange thing.
Where do you aim?
At the face?
Or...
You aim at his ass.
No.
Not the charger.
The thick orange one that...
Get his ass.
Oh, his face.
His face?
Yeah.
You aim...
Oh, that guy over there.
Minto, do you see this thing?
Shoot him.
Get him.
Kill him.
That thing over there?
Shoot him.
You see this thing?
Do not shoot him.
It's a hell bomb.
Oh, okay.
Shoot it.
All right.
So if I back up...
Shoot him, Mint.
Now you shoot at it.
Let the demons win.
This one?
Now watch what happens.
Oh.
Yay.
Woohoo.
Yeah.
That's really good for hordes.
Oh, yeah.
Democracy.
We love explosions.
My samples.
Samples is like what you take to upgrade your ship slowly.
You're always going to need common samples forever.
Where do you get the items?
Where are you finding these?
It's on the ground.
Oh.
Oh, do not go in there, Henya.
Don't worry.
You'll get better at spotting them, my love.
Okay.
Let's go.
Woohoo.
It, like, trust me, even me sometimes I have a hard time, like, running around and figuring out where I'm going.
I got you.
Oh, I got it.
Nice!
I got it.
I dropped a grenade!
My grenade!
Did you guys see that sick throw that I didn't fuck up twice?
How are you all the way over there?
Who?
Matara, you.
I saw it.
I saw you throw two grenades over there.
Oh my God.
You know what, Henya?
No, no .
Oh.
Oh!
I misplayed so bad!
She's dead!
So this is what you can do.
So you can reinforce, Mint.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, try it, try it!
What do I do?
Nice saving my life.
Control, and then you go up, down, right, left, up.
Oh, up, down, right, up.
What a gamer.
I know, that was gaming.
And then you yeet that to the fucking sky.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
There you go!
Come on!
Come in!
Watch out, you might dive into the helipod!
I'm coming!
Meow!
Oh, there you are.
This is meowing.
Bug breach detected.
So, Mint, you know how you, like, are low on supplies?
Since I have a supply pack, I can give you a refill.
Oh, okay, thanks!
Wait, how do you know I'm low on supplies?
Because the little diamond on your chest is glowing, it says give refill.
It does?
Yep, yep, yep.
Oh, watch out!
Watch out, watch out!
Your chest revealed your secrets.
Ahhh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I forgot I have the impact grenade.
It's kind of harder to hit stuff.
Oh, I think I'm dead?
Okay, one second.
She's dead, she's dead.
I was killed by myself.
I'll reinforce you in a minute.
Take my eagle!
Wait, where did he go?
I have the impact grenade.
Oh, I should have used the machine gun.
You were right.
One more, one more, one more.
Take my grenade!
Oh, wait, no!
Get her, Hanya!
Oh, shit!
I'm right here!
Good job!
Nice!
Alright, so over here, Min, you'll be a natural in no time, Min.
Don't even sweat it.
This is one of the missions.
So if you open up your map, you see how it's orange?
Yeah.
That's one of the main missions.
Oh!
So this one is upload data, so basically do the stratagem thing, but you just see how it's going.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I see it.
And then you just basically stand here and protect the area.
Oh, okay.
I can do that.
Until it uploads all the corn into that thing.
Yep.
Corn?
Yeah, corn.
What?
Corn.
No, no, no, no, no.
Corn!
This is the corn, the glowing pieces, right?
Oh, Hanya, what's the word you learned the other day?
I love corn.
Canto!
Wait, what?
I'm serving canto!
I tried to tell her not to, but...
Oh, you're serving canto?
I'm so proud of you, Hanya!
Yay!
Thank you!
This is my day four serving canto!
Can you jump?
Canto!
No, no, no, no, no.
If you really want to emphasize that, you gotta say cant without the to.
Canto!
Yeah!
That's what I'm talking about!
Say hi to my wife!
Both of my oshis are always serving.
Wait, both?
Who's your other oshi?
Kiwawa!
Oh, Kiwawa!
Oh, it's true, she does!
She's serving canto!
Oh, there's throwing up on us!
Shoot him at the face, bitch!
I'm trying to run away!
Wait, how do I get to my machine gun, you guys?
You can see on your map if you maybe dropped it.
Oh, I dropped it?
Also, don't be afraid to use to use to jump out of attacks.
If you notice that the monsters are coming in or they're shooting you or anything.
Also, reload is like you should not do the reload until your ammo runs out too.
Oh, okay.
You know in some games, here if you have a little bit of ammo and you use it, it loses the full ammo pack.
Oh, really?
I know it feels overwhelming at first, baby, but don't worry.
You'll get the hang of it real quick.
I'm just shooting.
I'm running and shooting.
Good, good, good.
Running and shooting.
That's my girl.
Actually, I can give you a shield that's gonna help you.
Yeah, let's do a...
Haru, do you want to do the blue mission or show them?
Oh, yeah.
Let's get...
Well, once you're done with the mission, the longer the mission goes, the harder it gets because there's more bugs that spawn.
And at the end, the more bugs on the map come to you.
But if you have extra time, you should always try to do side missions.
So the blue on the map, if you open tab, you see a little blue thing?
That's a side mission.
So it's gonna give us a little bit more.
You should come get your stuff over here, Mint, where I'm at.
Wait, where are you?
Yeah, exclamation mark, Mint.
I see people in chat are wondering who Mint is.
Exclamation mark, Mint.
Hi, it's me!
She's my pod gal.
It's me, Mint!
Come on, Mint!
It's a Mint!
Oh, shit!
She's out here flaming!
Wait, okay.
I already have one, I think.
Wait, how do I change?
Okay, there we go.
We're good.
We're gonna make Mint do the mission.
I wanna watch her suffer.
Me?
Yeah, it's not actually suffering, the mission.
You're so cruel.
Always, baby.
I got you.
I'm joking.
I got you, baby girl.
Mint, I don't think you heard me about this.
What, am I here?
I'm ready for this?
This way, this way, this way.
Go to this terminal.
I'm here.
I'm ready.
I'm at the terminal.
Touch that terminal!
Put in the Kodami code once it shows up!
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Kodami code.
Do it.
Wait, what it is?
Press E again.
And then you press up.
There you go.
I hate always getting behind this little guy.
Oh my god, this is me.
I'm spreading lies on the internet.
Stop spreading.
I'm uploading lies.
This one's a turning the tower.
So do you see this thing rising up?
Yes, I see it.
Usually, this is a two-person mission.
Because all you have to do is spin this thing and if you hear the beep on the terminal, then that means you have successfully aligned it.
So Hennye will turn it and you can go back to the terminal and you can tell her which direction to turn it.
I'll turn it, I'll turn it.
Wait, how do I?
Which way?
You can go to the terminal, Mint.
And then you can tell Hennye where to turn.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got this, I got this.
Um...
You...
The line is in between the dotted lines and this little colored area.
That way.
Wait, what?
Um...
There's a guy coming.
I think I'm gonna die here.
I am yelling.
Um...
Would you forgive me if I summon a resupply?
I would.
I'm okay!
I can't die.
How far should I keep going?
Um... I don't know.
Wait!
You're the one who's supposed to know about this!
Right there.
Wait.
So you see how that was a colored area?
That's where you have to put the...
the tower in between.
I don't know what I just did.
But I did something.
You did great!
That's all you need to know!
You did amazing!
Yippee!
So if you open up your map and zoom out, you can see all those diamond shit.
And all the things that we can clear.
We can get all of them.
Diamond shit!
I'm gonna collect diamond shit!
Tanya loves the treasures.
Oh, watch out!
I might need a...
Wait, why can't I... Oh, reload.
You might be out of ammo.
Which is why I'm here!
To give you resupply.
Thanks.
And now I'm out of my backpack.
Uh-oh.
Let's go get a diamond!
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine!
Are you sure you're good?
Oh, I see I'm exploding things!
Diving time!
I am living my best life.
It looks like you're in trouble, my friend.
I'm here to help.
Ow!
I am shining bright like a diamond.
I can't see shit.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Where's the resupply?
There's a supply over here.
I don't think you can really see it because...
Where's the resupply?
Did I not summon it?
There's a diamond over here.
You guys, did I forget to summon the resupply?
Did I screw it up?
Oh, that's a thing.
I just took the air strike.
Is it on cooldown?
I can't move with the fire!
Here, I can summon it.
Okay, yeah, perfect.
I had forgotten to summon the resupply, my bad.
I got your back.
I think I'm dead!
I got you, I got you!
You're alive, you're alive.
Thank you.
No!
Wait, wait, I'll call...
I already called, I already called, no worries.
I got a stim.
Can I get another resupply?
I got up to six damage.
Hold on.
Feed mommy.
Wait, wait.
Here you go.
Okay.
Give me.
Thanks, baby.
Did it work?
Yeah, it did work!
Thank you!
Okay!
You're doing great, Mint.
You're doing really good, Mint.
I didn't do anything.
At first, you just gotta get used to the positioning and stuff like that, right?
I'm gonna go get the stuff that you dropped back here.
All the white icons?
Yeah!
Oh, I'll come with.
Oh yeah, Mint, Mint, Mint.
Next game, I'm gonna summon a shield for you.
It's gonna help you a bit with getting hurt.
It's gonna do a little bit more damage and then it respawns.
It's cause she's far now.
Oh, woah.
Woah, woah, woah.
Oh no!
Have fun!
This is level three!
So sometimes when we get into big bug fights, like when the bug breach happened or anything, we, usually what we do is like we alternate using our big abilities.
Oh my god!
Yeah?
I'm listening.
Which is like when you fall in from the ship.
That really helps.
I died.
Who wants to reinforce her?
I'm busy!
I'm far from you guys.
I got it!
Oh wait.
I did it!
Are my egos forever?
Cause I feel like I've had so many of them.
Egos are unlimited.
Oh, I didn't realize.
There's a lot of guys.
Oh yeah, that's why I'm always...
I love egos.
It's so good for the...
Yeah, for clearing the nests.
Looking for the samples while I'm here.
Yeah!
I hate spears.
Reinforcement!
Where's my samples?
You guys see them?
Oh no!
Oh shoot.
I think I'm in trouble.
I think I'm in trouble!
You're fine.
Take my ego!
Oh my god.
Oh I'm dead.
I'm so dead!
Hahaha!
Did I kill you?
Sorry, baby!
Oh, I think you'll rearm.
Penga, that's really soft!
Well, I summoned you, okay?
That's really soft!
I'm the one who summoned you, Penga.
No!
It's called mistakes, you know?
Mistakes were made.
Is there a good way to see where I dropped my stuff?
Yeah, if you look at your map, it's gonna show you where your stuff was.
What does it look like?
Maybe that?
It looks like a gun!
It looks like the icons of your stratagems, for example.
It looks like a gun.
I love that.
No, I think I helped.
The yellow symbol.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
Yeah, trust me.
Even I completely lose myself in this game.
What's this?
I play it quite a bit.
Oh, someone's machine gun.
Oh my god, the stupid impact grenades!
Is it mine?
Oh my god, I missed every single shot that I took.
It was mine.
I cannot believe this.
This is my gun.
Mata, do you require assistance?
I have one big impact grenade left!
And I missed it.
Sweet liberty!
Liberty, liberty!
Come here for a second, actually.
This actually works out.
This here is called a friendship door.
I'm coming.
I have a minute and a half left before my other stuff pops up.
It's fine.
What's this thing?
Go to that yellow thing.
And you and Hennia hit it at the same time.
You don't have to count down, but Hennia can hit it.
Where is it?
Come here, man.
This way, this way.
We're teaching men how to play this game.
Down there.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ready?
Nice!
Now you can get the shit in there.
It's the shit!
Yeah, what Hennia said.
What's in there?
Shit!
Well, there's grenades in here.
Oh, we got breakfast system slips, which is really nice, too.
Oh, I forgot.
I have to use my grenades.
You can shoot the cylinders that sparks.
Oh, thank you.
I had no idea.
There's... oh, no.
Oh, there's little buddies that are dead here.
Hi, guys.
33 seconds.
He's fine.
Oh, no!
Oh!
Oh, the other cylinders.
Thank you.
Alright, 20 seconds.
Hey, Mint?
Yeah?
Can you come here for a second?
What if I throw my arc thrower in there?
This is going to be a weird request.
Can you punch me?
Do you think that's going to work?
I'm stuck.
There you go.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Yeah.
I don't think it worked.
I don't have a good punch.
Only bloodied a little bit.
I might have broken two of my ankles.
This might be a dumb question, but will I die in the fire?
Yes.
I'm missing a grenade, so I can't...
Okay, there we go.
Never mind.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.
I had already summoned the eagle when she came in.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to summon you a shield.
Okay?
Where are you?
I'm here.
Yeah, you'll see the little shield.
This?
Wait, wait, wait.
Let it drop.
Don't stand under it.
I should have let you stand under it.
I was like, wow, that's a cool looking shield.
Wow.
See, like right now, I have to apply to you, but it's touching the shield instead of you.
So you can handle it.
Oh, by the way, this is a bug breach.
Do you see it right there?
It's a bug breach, baby.
What's a bug breach?
So usually the bugs, it's like little patrols that they send.
So when you see that, that means you're getting attacked by like a group of bugs, which is fine.
It happens quite often.
It happens, you know.
I'm going to go get the shinies.
It's just life.
It's my cousin.
He's shiny.
I'm going to go get the shinies, too.
Bata, you have to protect Mindanaar behind.
Is it...
Oh, my God.
I'm going to die.
Just run.
If you're like outnumbered, just run.
I'm trying to run.
Just keep running.
Keep running.
You have a friendship door that I need to...
Run and then turn back in front of it.
That's usually the way.
You run and gun into us and then we run and gun and help.
I have a Harunya door to open.
It is what it is.
And now I'm here for Harunya!
I think Harunya is cute, but I think Hentara is better.
That's my favorite ship, Hentara.
I think that's...
I think you're wise.
Bata, I thought you were trying to get my visa.
Yeah, you're trying to get our visa.
Yeah, my visa.
My precious visa.
You got good shit in there, Harunya.
I mean...
You know.
If one doesn't help the other, I can think you're very cute.
Come here.
Shoot this explosive barrel right here.
I'm gonna go over here and shoot it.
Where?
This red one?
This one?
I'm gonna make our way down.
Where are we going, Nagin?
I would run away if I were you.
Oh, we got some stuff though.
What's that?
Oh, the blue one!
Hey, that's my stuff!
Don't touch my stuff!
This is some cool stuff!
Wow!
Nice!
Yeah, I'm gonna just...
Stop touching my stuff!
I think it's just ammo.
Time to go.
Also, get into the habit if somebody dies in front of you just to resummon them right away.
Extraction is available.
It would be a good habit.
Wait, how do I use your gun?
I took your gun and I know how to use it!
It doesn't have bullets, so you can shoot it and then you have to let it cool down.
Like it gets red because it's an energy gun.
Oh!
But it's good because you don't have bullets.
Can I get summoned back, please?
Oh, Mint, you got this.
I think I'm gonna die.
I think I'm in trouble.
I think I'm in trouble a little bit.
You got this, Mint.
I believe in you.
I have no gun.
Wait, maybe this one.
Oh, this one.
I'm sorry, I just found the penis clock and I'm excited.
Don't call it that.
We're in polite society.
That doesn't look like it!
Don't call it that, Mint, please.
She's gonna get embarrassed.
That person needs to go to the hospital!
How's that any different?
What's happening?
That means slay!
Mouse told me about it!
Slay!
Don't say it to your father.
She was asking if she could say that to her dad.
What about if I already did?
Then what did he say?
Oh, he was laughing about it.
Who told you that?
I told my dad and I said mouse.
He was like, oh, is that the one girl who played Fortnite?
And she's fine.
She's cool.
Because he loves Fortnite.
Oh, he's not like other dads.
He's a cool dad.
I'm sorry, I dropped your stuff.
It's fine, it's fine.
You guys want to go to the extraction zone?
He was claiming himself GigaChad.
He's a GigaChad?
Alright, I'm gonna start...
Okay, uh...
Mint and Henya, come with me.
Once you're done with the main mission, do you see the blue light on your map?
You can also find it on your map, but that's where we gotta go.
We gotta defend that zone for about two minutes.
I don't see a blue light.
Do you see, like right in front of you, do you see there's a blue light going up to the sky?
Oh, that one!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So we're gonna run to it, because there's no...
Once you've collected mostly everything, there's not really a use.
I'm getting the other two.
What do you think?
Also, Mint, when I first played, all I did was run after people.
So don't worry if it takes you a little moment to, like, get used to the game.
I've been shooting...
That's what I still do.
I still run after people.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was full of people, because I don't know where to go.
This is why I invited Haruka.
Because I'm okay with doing missions, but I needed somebody who's, like, good with doing missions.
Hi!
I'm Fisa.
You're great.
I'm not your god gamer.
She's a god gamer.
When we play on high difficulty, Haruka's soloing.
She's doing crazy stuff.
Get him, Mint.
I'm mowing him down!
Mowing him down!
Okay, kill the one with the orange.
He's summoning more.
Oh, this guy?
But it's okay.
When you see him, like, poop orange into the air, it's because he's summoning guys.
Don't worry.
I'm fine.
I just think it just went down the wrong tube.
You okay?
It happened.
So I don't want to scare you girls, but we're about to get a lot of bugs.
They're all about to come to us, which is why you should always try to finish the missions not super late on high difficulty.
Don't spit on me!
I think we'll be fine on level 3.
Oh yeah, we'll be more than fine.
I was gonna say, I think we should turn it up a bit.
Oh!
Oh god, I think that'd be super funny.
Let's try 4 and then we'll see how it goes.
RELOAD!
OUCH!
I wish I had my machine gun!
Eagle!
You can summon another one.
Oh my god.
They go on cooldown.
Summon the one you want.
I'm getting tackled by this guy.
Run towards us.
If you're in a situation where you're getting attacked a lot, run towards your allies because they will be able to shoot the bugs off.
Yeah, you're right.
You're so right.
And sometimes a grenade is faster than other stuff.
True!
I keep forgetting to throw my grenades.
That's okay.
Trust me, it's pretty overwhelming the first time.
But you're doing really good.
Oh, by the way, don't worry about the timer.
It's just letting us know how much time we have left to use the stratagem.
I'll be honest, I didn't even see a timer.
Now I feel stressed.
No, I'm just kidding.
Now I feel stress and anxiety.
Yeah, I could have lived without that knowledge.
That information.
I can't believe you would be this insensitive to my feelings.
Sorry, it's just the Canadian in me.
Sorry.
It's just the Canadian that's coming out.
Is it too late now to say sorry?
Probably.
It's funny because that guy is smaller than just your body.
I'm missing your clear landing zone.
They're very delicious.
I think we cleared it.
Yeah, I was gonna say, I think level 3 might be a little too easy.
I had to get ready for a bunch of bugs and it was kind of mid.
Okay, girl, we'll put you on 5.
We'll put you on 5.
Mid Tara.
I am pretty mid, I'm not gonna lie.
I am the equivalent of mid.
I was like, it's here!
If people ever want to call me something, like make fun of my name, they can call me mid to mid.
Press C.
Then just go in.
Nice!
Look at you crawl!
I noticed she was stuck, so...
Makes first mission!
Yay!
We survived!
Yahoo!
I am impressed because when my first time didn't kill me like 100 times on my first play and nobody kill each other.
This is amazing!
The night is young, Henya.
I'm full of dangers.
Uh oh.
We got 3 stars, we did everything.
Yippee!
That's true, Mint, you did kill me.
Henya, Mint killed me.
I did?
Remember when you shot the barrel and I died?
That was really cool.
That was me?
Yeah!
You shot the barrel, Mint.
You told me to.
I was just being a good listener.
Who knew that Helldivers is so much easier when we're not playing with Zentreya?
Because she kills us all the time, Mint.
I remember they kill me every single time and so many times.
I'm not even bloody.
But just a little bit bloody.
I've seen some things in my time.
Okay, Mint with a 71% accuracy.
You have the highest accuracy of all of us, Mint.
Let's go!
199 friendly damage.
See, I told you I was good at gun game.
Pew pew.
Pew pew, okay.
You don't have it.
I know, I know, I know.
I have the most accuracy.
I'm teasing, I'm teasing.
I was immediately gunned for it.
I was so used to it.
I was like, oh it's that thing.
I'm not here anymore.
Do I just return to ship?
Oh yeah, I'm about to pick a harder mission.
You stay here, Mint.
Oh, we'll give you a fun mission.
Wait, how do I do emote again?
Don't return to ship.
Oh yeah, it's alright.
I got confuzzled.
You're still on 3?
We're about to change it.
Try her on 9?
I don't even enjoy 9.
I think I'm ready.
Mint, Mint, look, look, look.
Your friends put me on level 9.
I have now PTSD.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Can I not change the difficulty in here?
Nope.
You have to leave the world.
And then be able to change it.
Oh my god, are you good?
It's okay, I want your blood on me.
You know, you can go back to the ice planet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yay, blood!
Nice, nice, thank you.
How do you emote?
B.
B?
B for bitches.
I just do this.
I do like a fist.
So do you see the acquisitions on your top?
So you press R and it shows you the different battle passes, but they're permanent so you can always get them.
So this is where you get your guns and emote and stuff like that.
So that's where we get most of our gear and stuff.
Like this one.
And you'll be able, as you keep playing with us, that's why I was doing all the side missions while you guys were running around.
So that way we have more money to spend.
Yay, nice.
Money, money, money.
Nah,
I like my impact grenades.
I don't want to switch them off.
Yeah, I like them a lot too.
This one is different.
So this one is a 15 minute mission.
Oh, it says clicking.
Usually when people get into that screen, people like to be like, let's drop here.
And then they just spam everything.
It's just to be annoying.
I don't even know.
I've been doing that since the beginning and then I infected all my friends with it.
She's been a little annoying since the beginning.
That's her Haru.
Big kiss.
We can try robots after two minutes.
Oh no, it's a robot.
Uh oh.
Are we killing?
I'm ready to kill.
I've never done this mission before, I think.
How do you see what the mission is?
Press Q.
Press Q and then you'll see.
Retrieve essential personnel.
The Terminate Advance has swarmed across this region leaving one of our top secret research stations surrounded by the enemy.
Use your clearance to unlock the emergency bunker doors and defend the facility staff as they enter to the evacuation shuttle.
Oh, is this the one where you print scientists?
We create people?
Yeah.
You basically, like, you click a button and then the people come out.
So you just gotta print them.
It's great.
This is the Clone Wars after all, my love.
Here we go.
Am I a clone?
Yeah!
You're a clone of yourself!
How do I use stims on people?
Ah, so you go to them and it says use stims.
Oh wow, that's handy.
But only when they're low health.
Oh yeah, speaking of stims, even if you have like, even like if you tripped on a rock and have like the minimal, like...
Why am I slowed?
Like for example, if you trip and have like a little damage done to you, I always recommend stimming.
It's always important to have...
I'm always out here stimming, Haruka.
Me too!
I'm fine.
But it's always good to use your stim because it gives you once you stim, you have like a few seconds of immunity as well.
So I always stim even though if I tripped on a rock and I'm like I have a boo-boo, I just stim that shit.
That's better.
Boo-boo!
Fire in the hole!
I didn't know you were an Overwatch gamer.
I hate it here.
I didn't know she was Junkrat.
Honestly, Mint and Junkrat do have a lot of similarities.
What's that?
Junkrat is the character in Overwatch that says Fire in the hole!
And that's just like me?
Yeah.
He's an annoying little Australian...
Rat.
I never played I scuttle around and I'm like That's like a PvP game, right?
Yup.
Overwatch is a PvP game.
I used to like Overwatch and Overwatch 1, but now I despise Overwatch.
Why?
What happened?
Oh my god, that's so dramatic.
No, I'm being honest.
Overwatch 1 was heaps better.
Overwatch 2 just completely... what really pissed me off was Overwatch 2.
Entire premise of its existence was to do PvE, story-based.
Then they cancelled that shit.
And then all they did is it's basically the same game, but like we're gonna remove one slot, so instead of six it's five people to play.
Like, the changes they've done to Overwatch 2 pisses me the fuck off.
I hate Overwatch.
I used to play Overwatch every day!
I used to laugh over it.
Guys, I'm sorry, we...
This is it.
Howard, if you're listening, I would love to get sponsored to watch the Fallout series.
Please do not take Haruka's words into your heart.
No, the Fallout TV series is great.
I've been watching a few.
I finished it!
I watched it!
It was so good!
I haven't seen it yet.
You watched it?
Henya, did you play Fallout?
The thing is, you can watch the...
I heard it's real good.
Yeah, I love it.
What do you watch it on?
It's on Amazon.
Amazon Prime!
You can what?
You can watch the TV shows without knowing anything about Overwatch.
Oh yeah, that is true!
You enjoy it a lot.
Fallout!
I meant Fallout!
Fallout, Fallout, Fallout!
Lots of Fallout!
In a radioactive world!
But yeah, that's why I don't like Overwatch.
I'm so sorry if you like it.
That's just my opinion.
How dare you have a different opinion than me.
I'm gonna throw a grenade.
Also, I mean, everything you said is valid.
You pressed G.
I don't think it works.
Oh, check your grenades at the bottom left.
Do you have 0 out of 4 grenades?
Did you use all your grenades?
No, I have 3.
Oh my goodness, there's a lot going on here.
Oh wait guys, I forgot this is only a 15 minute mission.
Oopsies, I'll come to you.
I was out here running around, but it's a 15 minute mission.
Me too.
What are we supposed to be doing?
We have to go to the orange thing.
Orange thing.
I completely forgot.
I'll meet you guys there.
Are you okay?
I got you, I got you!
Grenade!
I keep throwing in like terrible...
I thought you could aim it, so I was like...
Yeah, I'm sort of...
You'll get the hang of it.
And then some grenades explode in a little bit.
Whoa!
Nice!
Ow!
My body!
What just happened?
We have to escort 35 people.
I don't know what... I think the game lied to me.
It said I was killed by Henya.
Wait, what?
No way.
I think the game lied.
There's no way that Henya would kill me.
I think the game is bugged.
The game is bugged.
Don't worry.
I think that's called copium.
No, it's not.
Isn't getting killed by your urchin kind of precious, though?
People would pay a lot of money for that.
Exactly what I've always wanted.
Yeah, there we go.
Yeah, not gonna lie.
Alright, I've never seen this mission before.
Where's my gun?
Over there, Mata, there will be like...
I will teach you the ways, Mata.
Yeah, I've never seen this mission before.
I think we just skipped past the 7 pretty quickly.
So over here...
Oh, at the bottom, right?
The computer?
Yeah, there's this little button.
You press it and three people come out.
It's the printing button.
I'll just start pressing.
I'm coming.
Do not shoot the little people walking, by the way, you guys.
Don't shoot the little people.
Shoot him!
I'm gonna shoot him!
Kill them all!
Democracy!
I think that's communism.
That's not very democratic of you.
Oh, uh, Haru?
Yes?
Where are you?
Because one of us needs to be on the end.
You're where?
I'm on the other computer.
The bugs are coming from here.
What's this?
Okay, girls, girls, come here, both of you.
Girls, girls, girls.
You're gonna press this button every time it's available.
One of you presses the button.
One of you defends near it.
Oh my god, little people!
Where's the button?
Oh, this button, this button.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How do you know when it's available?
Lights up?
It'll blow.
Look at him running around.
These stupid little people.
They don't know how to play with a bug.
They're dumb little clones.
Fuck you.
Just any time you have the button, just press it.
Okay.
Just any time you can.
Oh, it's ready!
Push the button!
Create people!
My children!
Yeah, you're a mother now.
Congrats.
Oh, I'm not ready for this responsibility.
It only created three.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's gonna keep creating three.
So just keep...
And Haru and I are gonna defend on each side.
You guys can shit out six people at a time.
Yeah.
Wait, there's another computer?
Six people!
Well, no, no.
You stay at the one you're at.
Okay.
You keep doing at the one you're at.
Oh, I see the other one.
Wait, should I go to it?
No, I got it.
Yeah, I'm doing the other one.
La la la.
More people.
Come out, little scientist.
It's the helldivers!
Why do you run like that?
Come on.
Get in shape.
Come on, diet.
How many people do we need?
A lot.
18 out of 35.
That's all right.
We got this.
Come on, citizen.
I'm gonna get a diet freedom.
I haven't put down my strategies yet.
What am I doing?
I would love a little sip of freedom.
Do you have the Dr. Pepper?
That's a very freedom, democratic drink.
No, it's just diet freedom.
It is?
Can I get a Nuka-Cola?
Real helldivers!
Go.
Stop oogling.
My man is stuck.
Never mind.
My favorite thing is that they go on top of the rock just to get to where they are.
How do you like the taste of freedom?
Freedom!
I'm not even doing anything.
I hope you guys are...
We're almost... keep printing, keep touching, keep doing.
I'm waiting.
Almost there, almost there, almost there.
Patience.
It's a virtue I do not have.
We know.
Oh, my machine gun.
Oh, wow.
That's a lot of things.
Oh, my God.
I'm right in front of the door.
Shit.
Run!
It's okay.
Run, run, run, little man.
Just run through.
Run, little man, run!
I'm printing more men.
Printing more men.
Come on.
The mother of men.
Printing men.
Run, my clones.
The mother of men.
Sons of the patriots.
Genome soldiers.
Three more people coming now.
They really are your genomes.
Run, my little genome soldiers.
Oh, my God.
Is that a Metal Gear reference?
I can't believe you just made a Metal Gear reference.
That's crazy.
I feel like I'm not doing enough.
Yeah, you're doing great.
You're doing the most important job of all.
Now we get the fuck out of here.
You're printing the little men.
Yay!
We did it!
Have you done the...
You can start this up over here, Mint.
Which one?
Where am I?
Over here.
I regret picking it.
Do you see my little white arrow thingy?
Come to it.
It's time for you to input the Konami code.
Oh, here.
Interact.
You got this.
Got it.
You're basically a soldier now.
Oh, my God.
You have now evolved to a super citizen.
Super citizen?
Does that mean I have to pay super taxes?
Yeah, you do.
Unfortunately, I cannot disclose this information.
But good luck.
Whoa, these are so awesome.
These are like turrets.
Yeah, it's my turret.
Be careful, though.
It can still kill you even though it's her turret.
Oh, just kidding.
I'll run away.
Yup, be careful.
Also, I'm sorry, girls.
I can't mute.
Thank you for the gifted.
Yay!
What's an anti-tank?
I really appreciate it.
Oh, wow.
It's a turret that hates tanks.
I'm joking.
Yeah, it hates it.
I think I just acquired it.
Don't shoot us with it.
Are you sure?
I think you should shoot us with it.
Do it.
I'm sure.
I had a shield.
You sucker.
I had a shield, Mint.
I had a shield.
My...
You know what?
I'm gonna drop my help pod right on your head.
Where are you?
I dropped on my dead body, actually.
You can grab the shield if you want, Mint.
No, no, no.
It's okay.
I should have given it to you sooner.
No, no, no.
Don't worry about it.
I'll worry about it.
Get it, Twisted.
Okay, these chargers, you see them?
The big guy with the big pouch on his butt.
You gotta pop the little pouch on his butt.
He charges on you.
I don't see what you're talking about.
He's at the bottom there.
Penia's attacking him.
I'm attacking something.
It's a bug with a big thick butt.
Got a big fat butt.
Gotta hit his butt.
I'm just shooting.
Hit the butt!
Oh, this guy!
Yeah, you see?
He's got a big butt.
Once you blow up the little ball on his butt, he dies like three seconds after.
Weak.
Why would you die once you're...
Oh, someone shot me and launched me into the fray.
Wait, what?
It wasn't me for real.
Be careful.
You might die.
Yeah, um, I'm okay.
Okay, guys, the ship is here if you want to go in.
There we go.
I'm trying to get up.
My murder is girls.
It's time.
I can't believe I lived.
How did I survive that?
I don't know.
Oh, whoops.
I somehow got it.
How did I live?
You're just too good at the game.
You're just a cracked gamer.
You're a natural.
I got blown up by the bugs and I flew to the bugs and then I...
There was rain of spiders and everything.
It's crazy.
You fell into the ring of spiders?
We survived.
How you liking it so far?
It's so fun.
We, at one point, Haruka and I played this until like 8 in the morning.
Because what happens is somebody will drop out and then another person will come in.
The lobby changes every time and we just played until 8 in the morning.
Outstanding patriotism.
That's the title of my ship.
It's the patriotism of patriotism.
I like that.
I think I'm the mother of battle.
The mother of battle.
My ship is called the Dawn of Eternity.
Oooh.
That's cute.
You should be badass.
I swear to God, man.
I'm happy you're back but fuck you.
Yeah, frick you too.
I can't believe this man SMH'd my head.
Whoa.
I'm green.
No I'm not.
I was looking at you.
Wait, why are you guys all green?
You would die.
I haven't showered in two days.
I'm clean.
This is another stupid defend mission.
I'm getting worse.
You've always been worse.
I'm getting worse though.
Can I get much worse than how I already am?
Get it twisted, Min.
I'm twisted.
My brain is twisted.
She twisted.
Every time I look at you it makes me want to have mint chocolate and I hate mint chocolate and this is all your fault.
See, that's where it's like a brainwashing.
Are you trying to brainwash me to like something that I hate?
Yeah.
Wait, you hate it?
Yeah, I don't like mint chocolate.
Bad taste.
You never liked the chocolate mint?
Never ever ever?
It just feels too strong in my mouth.
I think when I was a kid I liked it but as I grew up I just enjoyed different tastes.
I don't hate it I guess.
That's my girl.
I like peppermint but you know what?
Maybe I should try mint chocolate now.
Yeah.
I tried them.
What's it called?
The ones that that have the dark chocolate and the white chocolate or not white chocolate the white mint inside.
I think it's after 8.
Oh, the peppermint patties.
Oh, never mind.
It's so good.
They are?
Peppermint patties?
Yeah, they're so yummy.
Isn't that girl scout ones?
No.
Oh, these things.
I don't think I've ever had them.
Those are mints.
Gosh.
Matara, those are mints.
The girl scout ones.
Oh, I'm ready.
Sorry.
No.
I like mints.
Maybe I should try these three one day.
And I'll message you going, they are still shit mint.
They're still really shit but I did it for you.
They still suck.
Yes, please report back to me.
Every year you should set a date for April 23rd where you try them and then you message mint and go, still sucks.
April 23rd?
That's not...
Wait.
Oh, I was thinking of 33rd.
I was like, there's no...
There is no 23rd.
What if I just make an entire documentary of me trying out mint chocolate just for you.
Be like, hi guys.
We're gonna get you...
I'm gonna send you a bunch of mint chocolates and then you can just try them all and you can decide.
Oh, wait.
Mint.
Grab the backpack.
I'm actually so down to do this.
I'll leave the backpack for you.
Where?
Give me all your favorite mint chocolates and that would be a fun collab to do actually.
Holy shit.
I'm so down to do this.
Wait.
Do they have a matcha flavor in the ice cream or is that only a Japan thing?
We do a little bit.
A little bit.
But it's not as popular here.
It's way more popular in Japan.
And the matcha in Japan is so good.
I never left my house.
I don't know what that's like.
Well, you and Henya are a little two hikikomoris.
Yeah, we never go outside.
Which is ironic considering my background.
Yeah, outside is overrated, babe.
Outside is scary.
Don't go outside.
What were you saying, Finn?
What were you asking?
I don't remember.
Welcome to the team.
Welcome to hell, my friend.
Oh, they're gone.
Oh, this is the one where you have to load the little Seath missiles.
Alright, let's do this.
Let's not throw a grenade for this one.
Cause we'll get more points if we don't actually do it.
What do you mean more points?
We get more points for stars.
Oh, that's a big one.
Oh, that's his butt.
That's his butt.
Stars?
Wait, how do I get your butt?
Get your butt.
That was where the thingy went in, no?
No, I want to see your butt.
Give me your butt.
There it is.
Oh.
She's staying suspiciously.
Oh my god.
I got killed
by Henya.
I think the game glitched again.
I got killed by Henya again.
Mata, can you revive all of us?
All three?
Alright, girls.
Make yourselves useful.
Grab an artillery missile and load them in.
I'm going back.
You can't tell me what to do.
I'm bringing back my stuff.
Go get your stuff.
You can see it on the map.
It's just that I was the only one alive.
So I'm the only one that can summon you guys back.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go get my stuff.
Yeah, you can go get your stuff.
You can see it on the map.
You can follow them.
These bugs are pissing me off, you sons of bitches.
These bugs were made for walking.
And that's just what they...
Oh!
That's just what they do.
The drop method is just how you...
How is that actually faster?
What the heck?
Where is my stuff?
Is that my stuff?
This is like...
This is speedrunner strat.
She's speedrunning?
It's cause... I didn't know how to speedrun a mission, but that's cause I never do the missions.
I always bring Haruka who always does the missions.
Where do I put it?
Are you okay?
You're okay!
No!
Watch this, Min.
Watch this.
Uh-huh.
Dead.
Is this the bug guy?
Or am I crazy?
Yeah, that's bug guy.
But if you have...
Charger!
So your weapon...
If you shoot at it...
Do you see these sparks coming out of it?
That means your IMO is not penetrating.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I noticed that.
So you have to hit his ass.
But for me, who has...
What I like to call the croissant cannon.
If I shoot his face at the right angle, I can one-shot him and kill him instantly.
Croissant!
It's called the croissart cannon, but I call it the croissant cannon.
Oh, my stuff is over here.
Oh, my stuff is over there.
You know what?
Let's just leave it alone.
No, go get your stuff!
Go get your shield pack.
There's a lot of guys over there.
They'll help you.
You got your friend.
No, they're dead.
All the guys are dead.
It's a woman's only game.
No men here.
I actually don't even know where my stuff is.
Oh, right here.
You're right.
Thanks!
My shield is back!
Now you won't die!
I'm coming back!
I died before though.
It's kind of crazy how that works.
So Henya's eagle also broke the illegal...
transmitter tower thingy.
Which is funny.
But if you actually do it legitimately, you get more points.
So I was gonna see if that was the case.
Oh, so Henya did it illegitimately.
Yeah, but it's okay.
I didn't realize I was so far on the map.
Wait, did I fuck up?
No!
We just get less points, but that's it.
Oh, ow!
Nice, I got rid of the nest.
Good job, girlies.
The bug nest, by the way, you'll see them in the future.
You gotta throw little grenades in them.
It's a tutorial, but they look different, so I don't know what they look like in the real world.
Yeah, because I keep killing them before.
I only know them in the mission.
The tutorial.
They haven't trained me for the real world.
I'll stop giving help from now on.
If you have questions, feel free to ask.
It's just that at first, when I first played, nobody explained anything to me and I had a really hard time streaming and following along.
No, you're good.
Did I do a bad job explaining to you?
My first game wasn't with you, baby.
And again, it's absolutely not, you know, a criticism.
I played with some lovely people who were great.
Yes?
Oh, you need some help?
I got you, baby girl.
Run.
I'm trying to run.
Oh, I'm running.
It sounds like a song.
I'm trying to run.
Oh, I need to reload.
I need to reload.
I need to run.
It's crazy, this beam.
I know.
You get it at level 20.
I was so happy when I finally got mine.
It's like a badge of honor.
It is.
It does take a little while, even if you play the game a lot.
I'd say still tell her about holding R.
Oh, yeah, if you are zoomed in on your gun, and you press middle button, it gives you like the extra scope, which I didn't find out until like two weeks ago.
Wait, what?
I didn't know about it.
I didn't find out until two weeks ago.
Wait, how do you shoot with what?
Let's say you're shooting your gun, right?
You're aiming with right mouse and then click middle mouse.
Isn't that crazy?
You can do that with every gun.
Oh, my God.
I didn't know that.
Also, another one.
Hold R, you can change the speed.
What?
Hold R.
On your gun.
And then what?
I believe, I can't exactly remember how to switch between the two, but like for my sickle, I'm shooting 100 M per minute.
100 bullets per minute.
Is that the fastest?
Because I only want to shoot faster, not slower.
Yeah.
The higher the number, the faster it is.
And how do you get the number up?
It depends if it's sideways.
I think you use your scroll wheel.
Oh, it's the sideways that means it's going to go faster.
I don't know which way I like more.
I'm trying to remember the patrols.
No, it's fine.
Don't worry about it.
Explosive barrel.
I got you, queen.
Oh.
Oh, there are guys over there.
What's this?
Note.
Oh.
Good job.
Wait.
I have like no bullets at all.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I can do a resupply.
Yeah, resupply.
You can resupply?
Yeah.
And then if you see these...
Wait, wait, don't open it, H4.
Once Mick gets here, I want her to see this and open it so that she sees what it looks like.
Okay.
May I take the stim?
Yeah, you can take the stim.
Thank you.
Is it the friendship door?
No, I want her to see what it's like when you...
when there's the little glowy stuff on the map.
So, Mint, come towards me.
Do you see... come here.
Do you see this big glowy thing where I'm here?
Where are you?
This can sometimes have extra guns or it can have like super credits.
Whoa!
What is that?
Reposition clips.
That's the stuff that you need to level up.
If you see a shiny spot, it's like a little treasure.
Yeah.
Always try to pick it up.
Charger!
A charger?
Wait, is that a charger?
Left 4 Dead.
Charger!
Left 4 Dead 2.
I want to play that game again.
Yeah!
What about Harvest Plate one day?
Well, yeah!
I don't think I've...
I played it, I think, only once.
Like a year ago.
Wait, am I okay?
Oh, no, I'm not okay.
I would avoid his...
His everything?
Yeah, you can like press off to get out of his attack.
Oh, I definitely did.
Yeah, I did that.
Oh, nice.
The shield also will absorb, I think, like one damage from him.
But I'm not sure if it's like a full.
I shot you with the shield.
I got him.
Good job!
Nice!
We have for some guns, if you hold R, you can change the speed a bit.
And I can't...
Oh, here we go.
That's crazy.
So if the bar is up on the gun, you scroll your wheel up to change it.
What the hell is this?
So now I'm used to seeing like one little bug nest.
Oh, wait, there's a bug nest.
Oh, yeah, Mint, Mint, Mint, I'll let you come.
Mint, you have to shoot your grenade inside the hole.
Okay.
Your grenade.
Come here.
Stand here.
But like you have to shoot it in...
Good job!
I did shoot it in!
I'm using the grenades that explode immediately.
So I forget that like regular grenades take a while to pop up.
Sorry.
No, you're okay.
Mine pops like right away.
This is great.
Oh my God, he was so cute right in my face.
I can do that, by the way.
I have the same flaws.
Here, now that I'm not being chased by 40,000 dogs, I can teach you what I was trying to teach you, Matta.
Sorry?
I can teach you what I was trying to teach you without being chased.
So stop moving and then hold R.
Yeah, yeah, no, I saw what it looks like.
Thank you.
It's like you hold R and then it like switches.
You just move your scroll wheel up to change your speed.
Wait, uh-oh.
I'm changing things and I don't know what I'm doing.
So 100 means faster, right?
Yes.
And you move your scroll wheel just up to change the speed.
So right now you see how...
Oh, I see, I see it.
So my default is I was just shooting slow?
No, 100 is the fastest.
People are saying that's range.
Oh, that's the scope of the gun?
Oh, it depends on some guns.
Oh, right click.
My chap said right click is speed.
Oh, I have a...
Oh, there's a flashlight.
Oh.
That's the scope.
Okay, so every gun is a little different apparently.
Okay.
Mom, what are you doing?
I genuinely didn't know.
What the heck?
I've never...
I genuinely had no idea.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna request reinforcement.
I'm so sorry everything go down.
I'm so sorry.
So for some guns, holding R changes the scope.
And some guns, like the machine gun, changes the speed of how you shoot.
Democracy is landing.
Wait, where's our stuff?
You can see it on the map.
That was so fucking funny though.
I'm so sorry.
The backpack is there if you want it, yeah.
That's true.
Some guns are different.
Just holding R changes your settings.
This is yours.
Yeah?
I'm going the wrong way.
Helldiver.
I have one right here too.
Your machine gun.
Oh, my machine gun.
Thank you.
You guys are so cute.
Kawaii.
No, you.
Tomodachi Kawaii.
I'm your friend.
Oh, no, no, big guy.
I guess it would be like Oshidachi or Tomooshi.
Tomoshi.
Tomodachi.
We're taking your combat zone.
Wait, wait.
Oh, no.
Are you a traitor?
Wait, I'm a traitor.
Are you a filthy traitor?
Wait, wait.
Don't get out of the combat zone.
How do I get back to the...
How do I get back to the combat zone?
You have to run back to the combat zone.
That's the way.
I'm not a traitor.
I cannot believe...
I think the game glitched again.
I said I was killed by Hanya.
Wait, what?
I didn't tell you.
We didn't glitch it.
I think the game is glitched.
We didn't glitch.
You're hoping.
Wait, I didn't kill her this time.
I didn't kill her this time.
Hanya, you're a murderer.
Hanya is a tiny little baby murderer.
I was going to do the shark song, but you're on the YouTube.
So we're going to be careful not to say that.
What song?
I was going to say baby murderer.
I think it's okay.
It's going to be like...
Oh, that definitely can't be the original.
Sounds like an old hag singing it.
He looks a little different.
Also, so this isn't just an ignorant question, my friend.
So you can't like do a little humming of songs or a little singing of songs on YouTube.
Wait, not even the humming?
No, you can, I think.
I think it's...
Oh, okay.
Is it weird that the Charger looks different than before?
It does look a little different.
He does, I think.
You never played it before!
This guy?
Oh, is he not the Buttman?
Yeah, he's the Buttman, but he looks a little different.
He looks more armored.
He also is taking a...
Oh, it is a different variant.
He's taking a ton of them.
Yeah, it's like a boss.
He's a boss.
He's not...
He's not a Buttman, he's a boss man.
He's a boss man.
Mr. Buttman!
Gun dancer!
Bring me a dream!
Buttman!
He's still alive!
Die already!
How is he alive without his butt?
I've never seen him before.
Stop camping!
He's obsessed with me!
I know why, but I can't...
He's alive!
He's still crawling, what the heck?
I've never seen one last so long.
Oh, he's dead.
Nice!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
Guys, I have a bad feeling.
Yup, we're gonna get bugged.
Sorry.
We're gonna get bugged?
I let them call it.
My bad.
Watch out, I'm gonna throw an eagle at it.
I already threw one.
I'm gonna go all the way over here, Dayo.
All the way over here?
Oh!
Uh-huh.
Or I just pinged.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Uh-huh.
Because this looks like an escort citizen's mission.
Okay.
I need to go get the...
I'm going to, I'm going to.
Which planet is this?
This is the defense planet.
The one that we have in the mission.
I am coming.
I'm coming too.
Help.
It's okay.
I had my shield.
Yeah, the robot, the little robot doesn't discriminate.
The little robot does not discriminate.
It's true.
He kills anybody.
I'm running.
Nice use of the little eagles.
Was that you, Mint?
Thank you.
No, I don't, I don't have eagles.
Oh, you haven't unlocked them yet.
I'll show you where to unlock them after this game.
Can you guys remind me?
Yep.
What?
Hey, Ma, make sure you tell Mint about the eagles stratagems.
Oh.
Oh, yeah, I will.
Yeah, don't forget about it, though.
Actually, Haruka, you can tell her about them.
Don't forget about it.
Because you can probably teach her how to aim better than I can aim.
Yeah, I'll help you.
I'll be with you.
I'll be your buddy, Matara.
No.
I just kind of say, fuck it, we ball and hope for the best sometimes.
Yeah, come.
I'm here.
Haruka, we're in polite society.
Mint is a polite little one.
This is...
She's on YouTube.
We can't be swearing like this.
Oh.
What?
Haruka.
I'm part of a freedom society, actually.
Um, a manager.
Oh.
I'm part of a rich democratic society.
Can I say fuck, then?
Can I say fuck, Mint?
If anything, you're unmanaged.
Wait, Mint, so does that mean I can say fuck now?
Oh, goddamn.
Yay!
She's going in.
Thank you, Mint.
I can say fuck now.
No, don't say thanks to Mint.
Say thanks to Neil.
Huh?
Thank you.
Always make sure to resupply, since you have a gun with bullets.
Yeah.
If you ever see bullets on the ground.
Have a gun with bullets.
Well, it's because mine...
Mine has bullets.
Mine all don't have bullets.
Look at you, fancy pants.
That's why.
I know.
I did it because...
Okay, see the one...
One of them is, like, spitting something.
He's, like, farting into the...
Oh, too late.
I didn't see.
It's all right.
We fart together.
I don't have to specialize.
Realize.
She believes.
My calories.
She lies.
Oh, no.
I hate the butt man.
It's okay.
I got him.
Um...
Oh, and they're always obsessed with me.
Oh, my God.
It's because you're smart.
You smell so minty.
So cute.
Let me kill the little bugs and they'll come help you.
This always happens at picnics.
The bugs come after me most.
Really?
Oh, you're gonna hate me.
They never come after me.
Oh, hello.
I...
The little guys are so annoying.
Like, they think they're a big deal, but they...
Yeah.
They just suck.
They're like two walls.
Little bugs in big numbers.
Little bugs, big adventures.
Hell, hell, hell divers.
Hell divers.
Who?
Who are you gonna call?
Help.
Divers.
My mom.
Beedity-bee-dee.
Your butt's real good.
Wait.
You have no hair.
Bustin'.
Bustin.
You always feel like you run out of bullets until you kind of start learning where to look for bullets and grenades.
Nades here.
Hold on.
This is SSD drive.
I'll give you a shield.
Oh, thanks.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Can Mint get 20 gifted too?
I can't be the one winning.
How about 21 gifted?
Can anybody has 21 gifted for Mint going once?
Wait, I forgot!
YouTube's doing the gifted thing now!
Yeah!
Yeah, it's been for a while.
I remember when YouTube didn't do that.
Okay, she's an original.
Thank you so much for the 20.
Pepperidge Farm remembers.
Oh, put that SSD into the thingy, hadn't ya?
They're doing the main quest, yeah.
Into this one?
Into the hole.
I'm just following you.
I see you have full grenades.
If not, pick up these grenades.
No, I'm full on grenades.
And then these are samples, by the way.
You see here?
Oh, we also gotta kill him.
Pick it up.
You pick it up.
There's usually more than one.
There's usually like two or three samples.
Couple samples, okay.
But I think here there was only one.
Henya is busting good.
She's busted.
Busting, busting.
Sometimes, you know, she'll come here and say stuff and I'm like, ah, gotta let her live her best life.
I love that one.
I'm happy.
Yay!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the gifts and you guys, thank you.
The Game Master does not like how fast we're progressing.
22 gifted subs going once?
We're fine, we're fine.
22 gifted subs going twice.
We're fine.
I hate this.
Yeah, and then this final mission is like right near where we're extracting.
But no.
Let's see what's up here.
Up here?
I'm following you, sorry.
Yay, I'm always trying to like double check around because I'm always looking for samples and stuff.
There's an extra gun here too if you have.
Another gun?
There we go.
But you already have a machine gun, I think.
Yeah, I do.
When you summon things, dude, doesn't it cost money?
Summon what things?
What do you mean?
Like if I have to summon ammo and stuff, does it cost money?
Nope.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's just that we all share a pool of some- so you have like- you see the stratagems that I used there, the eagles?
That'll have a limited amount of those.
So then the resupplies, they go on cooldown.
Same for your gun.
Like your gun is free, but it has a cooldown.
You can only summon it like three or four times in a game.
Which is why when you die, it's nice to go back to your old gun and pick it up.
Yeah.
Okay, that makes sense.
Is that like 300 gifted?
Why not 400, huh?
We gotta go back.
Evacuate the winter citizen people.
Go back where?
I could stay here and do the bug nest and then activate the...
I'll stay.
You know what?
You go.
I'll go by myself!
Yeah, I'm going too!
I'll stay.
I was gonna go, but if we're... You can do whatever.
You can do whatever.
I just want to clear the little bug nest so we get more experience.
Yeah!
At least Hanya's coming with me.
Okay, then I'll come with you.
I'm coming!
We're coming!
I'm gonna... I'm a little slow.
But I'm alright.
Oh, you're coming with us, Nick?
Yeah.
Okay, I'll wait.
I'll get you.
No, no, no, you don't have to wait.
I'm waiting.
We're waiting.
Oh no!
Wait!
Shoot him!
No!
Oh my god, I activated a bug breach.
We're getting comfortable here.
Hey, Mint!
Oh, wow!
Hello!
We've been waiting for you.
Sorry, it took so long.
Kept you waiting.
Hold on.
There we go.
Oh, oh!
It's a dog pile now!
Well, we haven't seen each other for three years.
We're gonna go up to close all the same.
Well, what's a better way to get back to knowing each other than, you know...
Collaborating!
Democracy!
Yay!
Great liberty!
I love liberty.
Sweet liberty!
Alright, I'm gonna give myself a resupply so I can fill up my pack pack.
I'm gonna climb this rock.
Maybe you shouldn't climb up that rock.
You're really close to that pen.
I feel like you might accidentally kill yourself.
I gotta run!
I'm okay!
Now watch this.
Boop, boop, boop.
Nice!
Oh, come here!
Come here!
Here you go.
Oh, thank you, Haru!
There you go.
Now everyone is beat up!
Thank you, thank you!
Ready to go!
I have the music turned off in this game, and my music's not playing, so this is a very, very relaxing stroll for me.
It's all quiet and shit, and I'm just like, oh, this is so peaceful.
And, you know, hanging out with my friends, and Mata might be dying, but it's okay.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm fine.
How are you doing, Matar?
Are you good?
I'm doing great.
You got it, you got it, Matar!
You activated the bug nest, and now I'm running back.
I'm taking a swim.
Taking a dive?
Oh, you got rid of the outpost.
Be careful not to drown.
Genuinely.
Can you actually?
Yeah, you can.
Probably.
Because, basically, your armor in the lore is really heavy, so you'll drown.
Oh!
Yep, you'll die.
I die so many times.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, Tenya.
Have you been to Fuji-Q?
Yeah, I have!
What's your favorite, favorite um, rollercoaster thing to do there?
It's great!
It's crazy!
Eigo!
What's the name of it, though?
Eigo?
Yeah!
So what is it, what does it do?
What is the attraction?
So usually, when you go on the rollercoaster, you have a place to put your feet, right?
Uh-huh.
But on that one, it's like you're in the mid-air, so you have to take off your shoes, and you're flying around in the mid-air, and then there's the spinning, 30-60 degree, and a lot of stuff.
Oh wait, that's the stuff I don't like.
The seats spin, too.
It's really crazy.
I also like Fujiyama, too.
Nah, it's gonna be fine.
And what's Fujiyama like?
Fujiyama is, I think it's the tallest one in Japan.
Oh, is it like the proper rollercoaster?
You go up, you go down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's one, there's one at the top, you get to see, like, a good view of Mount Fuji.
Oh, I like that, I like that.
If you're wearing glasses, you have to take it off.
Food?
It's fine, it's fine.
I think they have like a little...
I don't know if they have a restaurant, because I've never been to, but they got a little like a market thingy going on outside, so you can just get some cheap food for 100 yen or 100 yen.
I feel like they have that everywhere, right?
Yeah, it's a little street.
Oh, that sounds so good.
That's not good.
Or they got the konbini.
It's really cool, so we just go konbini and get some stuff, and we're just ready to go back on the rollercoaster.
That's what I do.
It's because in, not in Japan, in like other countries, usually the whenever you go into the amusement park, you can't come out.
So they make you curious that you order expensive food.
What?
I've always been able to... You can?
You can go back out.
Really?
Yeah.
I guess maybe just like Canadian things.
Because they...
Oh my goodness.
There's usually no food near it, so you basically have to eat over there.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
But they let you leave, because they'll sometimes stamp your thing, right?
Yeah, they give you a little stamp on your body.
Oh yeah, that's true.
For a lot, there's no food.
There's usually no food nearby, so that way you kind of have to buy food there, which is pretty expensive, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, there's a little man.
There's a little man.
Got a moosh, got a moosh.
Moosh, moosh, moosh.
I think it's a... Yeah, there you go.
Hi, man!
Can I punch the man?
These are my clothes!
I punched the man.
Don't punch my people!
Come here, little guy.
Give me your lunch money, idiot.
Oh my god!
Wow, Mint, you've changed ever since you came back from your graduation.
You've changed.
Oh my, oh my!
They're going after the little man!
Oh no!
Not the little man!
Imagine being a little man in the world.
The bugs are coming after you, the little ghosts are coming after you, everyone's coming after you.
Stop it!
Stop attacking me, you stupid little guy.
Uh oh.
I can't get your butt.
Oh, I almost... Oh, I killed him!
Good job.
You almost got me.
Watch this.
Oh, yeah.
I'm watching.
Watch this.
Watch out for the little man.
I kind of stood in front of him.
What's going on?
I'm okay.
You're doing amazing.
Oh, that was...
How's he live?
I'm gonna go create more men.
Oh, we lost three.
Oh, no!
Create more men.
I require more vestine.
Watch out, Mint.
I'm watching.
Oh, last reload.
What's that mean?
It means that's your last reload, baby.
It's a fire one.
Oh, I have to switch.
He's gonna die right now.
Final reload.
Uh oh.
Don't worry.
We only got ten minutes to save the world.
As soon as you guys are done, I'll start activating the teleporter back home.
Watch out, little man.
Keep running.
Watch out, Steve.
Matata has the same bug build as me.
Are you also big-breasted and big-hipped?
And six-clawed?
Let's go.
I like how you did mention the big-breasted part.
Yeah, you know what, Matata?
I went to your Twitter to see, like...
Yeah, big breasts?
Yeah, I saw big breasts on your fucking Twitter page.
Uh-huh.
Go on.
What do you mean?
I don't know what that was all about.
Now you got Mint's attention.
You just have to mention big breasts.
I gotta be polite when she's over here Googling about it.
Sorry, Haruka, for interrupting.
What were you saying?
So you went to see big breasts and...
On your Twitter banner.
I wanna know what the hell...
You like them?
We need to add Henya.
That initial Twitter banner.
It should be, like, Mies and Treya and Henya.
Wait, are you talking about that picture?
Yup.
You know exactly what picture I'm talking about.
What the heck, Niall?
Do we need more men?
No, we're all good.
We just need to go home now.
Oh, okay.
I'm allergic to men now, so I'm going home.
What does the go home look like?
It's where I am.
Come to where...
Oh, yes, that's right.
That one.
Yeah, that one.
You can also press tab and you see that orange icon that has an arrow going up.
Yeah.
That's the extraction point.
I can't start it right now because I got too many bugs around me, but I'll start it in just a minute.
Oh, hey, guys.
I found a friendship door.
A friendship door?
Mint, do you want to come open this door with me?
I'd be honored.
I'd be honored if you opened it with me.
Oh, gosh, I'm out of stamina.
Tomodachi.
I'm coming.
This is the ritual to be like, welcome back.
Friendship door.
Alright, here we go.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
We might have got some cool stuff.
Oh, yeah.
What did we get?
We got a sample and...
What's that?
A star wall.
And some stims.
That's a gun.
Can I please get a little bit of help soon, please?
You're a gamer.
You've got this.
We'll take our time.
I'm just going to take a leisurely stroll.
I don't think I have any...
I have like zero stims.
You got it.
My boba don't have stim packs.
They're filled with momos.
That's where I hide my momos before I eat them.
I'm pretty sure you hide some stim packs inside.
You got this.
No, I hide my momos before I eat them.
How do I get the other packs?
Samples.
Samples!
Wait, how do I get around there?
Uh-oh.
He's over here.
I got you, fam.
Thanks, fam.
Love you.
I thought you were gay.
Take my ego!
Yay!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, Henya!
I would think that was personal if I didn't know you a little better, Henya.
No, you didn't die.
You're fine.
I didn't die yet.
The night is young, Henya.
Anything can happen in full of boba.
You didn't die.
That's important.
I mean, Min, we can just watch this from afar if you want.
I like to get bloody.
The night is young and filled with boba.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
She's a little...
Watch out for your right...
Freak!
I'm a little freak!
Yeah, you are.
I want your blood on me!
Yep.
The smaller they are, the more...
Freak!
The closer they are to hell.
Yeah, there we go.
Oh, that's definitely not me then.
Freak!
Oh, Henya, you're pretty small and pretty crazy.
Nah, nah, nah, nah.
Henya, I think you're fucked up like the rest of us.
Not as much as you!
Um, what do you mean?
Nah, not as much as you!
I don't know, I might have...
killed a few things in my day.
That's in Nepal.
Haru, you're the most toxic Canadian I ever see it.
Yes.
It's not gonna hit us, you know.
I know.
I put it over there, though.
Haru, Haru, Haru!
You're the most toxic Canadian I've ever seen it before.
That's an honor.
Because there's not a lot of us in this world anymore.
We Canadians are going extinct.
Canadians are going extinct.
There's barely any Canadians left.
Every time Americans I meet online, I see one Canadian.
And we all go feral because we never meet a Canadian online.
It's true.
I feel like there's so many Canadian VTubers.
There are.
Yeah, there are so many.
Yeah, but for us Canadians, we can't...
Okay.
I don't know how to explain for us Canadians, we don't see each other ever.
Uh oh.
Wait, wait, can you tell by their... how they talk?
Can you tell they're Canadian or American?
No!
Can you tell?
Uh, no.
Oh.
Because we've been so critically online that our accent gets hidden away.
It does.
I see it.
It only happens with some words like sorry, bag, tag, leg.
Bagel.
And bagel.
I say bagel.
Bagel.
What is the Canadian way of saying bagel?
Bagel?
No, it's bagel.
It's bagel.
Bagel.
Sweet liberty!
My leg!
I feel really patriotic right now.
Right?
This game just brings out the patriotism.
My guy has survived three missions and it's so fucking dirty.
Holy shit, he needs a bath.
I am so covered by blood.
Haru, can you show her where to buy stratagems and stuff?
Minto!
And where to buy everything.
I have to pee.
I trust you guys.
Minto!
It's this computer thing.
You press E to ship management.
And then you see...
Go to stratagems.
And then ship module.
This is where you get...
So on the top, this is where you see all your samples, all your requisition slips, and then the blue icon is your super samples.
Right?
And so this is where you get all your stratagems.
Which you need all the requisition slips for.
But the ship module, if you go here, this is where you can unlock things for your ship which helps enhance your stratagems that you use.
I can't get anything.
But that's okay.
If you play this game a lot, we'll be grinding and get you so many samples and your ship will be fucking clogging.
Yeah!
Yay!
Well yeah, that's that.
Thank you for watching my tutorial.
Make sure to like and subscribe.
Wait, so I can buy...
I can get a sniper rifle?
Yeah!
Wait, against light vehicle armor.
So not the butts.
I mean you could do for bugs, but it's more so if they have penetration armor on them.
I said the butts.
The butt.
Oh there's...
The anti-tank.
That's the thing that will blow up the butt.
Yeah!
Blow up the butt.
What is this?
Finding Nemo?
I kinda want the rifle though.
It's up to you.
I like being a sniper.
Sniper?
I love being a sniper too.
It's one of my favorites.
I think I haven't tried it yet.
But I'm shit at the sniper at every game, so...
I try.
If you scroll...
Oh there is!
Oh the...
The eagle...
Strike and die.
Do you guys do the eagles?
Yeah, I use the eagles a lot.
I use the eagle air strike.
It's the one that I use.
Me too!
But I got the 5 kilogram ton bomb.
Yeah, you have that one.
And I think you also use the cluster bomb.
The cluster bomb?
Yeah, it's when you throw and it's a cluster.
And while your air strike goes in a straight line.
Where you throw.
Yeah!
So cute!
What's that thing?
The eagle air strike.
An eagle never misses.
Eagle never misses.
But it misses.
But it never misses!
Yeah, it never misses.
It's not them missing, it's us missing.
Okay, hold on.
What's worse?
Them or us?
Us.
Because we're...
Wrong!
No eagle misses!
Yeah!
If it misses, it's the government's fault!
Government!
Yeah!
You can get the eagle if you want.
I like the eagle.
I don't know.
I like eagle too!
I have like a bomb thing but I haven't used it.
Because I'm bad about remembering to use it.
Well...
You'll get used to it.
Maybe I will get the rifle though.
It's up to you.
The best part is experimenting and having fun.
Whip.
Get the sniper then be disappointed?
Why is it disappointment?
Well, it's a shitty gun.
I see.
The material rifle.
I'm looking at your stream.
Yeah.
It's a shit gun.
Wait, the sniper is good now?
Oh, it's good now?
Hi!
Oh, it's for bots.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, master.
Master.
It's a fire gun.
Fire gun.
Oh, Henya.
I need your advice.
What is it?
A friend and I disagree on this.
When I go to maid cafes with this friend, I will say I love you to the maids.
And they love it.
And my friend says it's embarrassing.
What do you think?
Well, the thing is I never really go outside.
I never went to the maid cafes.
I don't know how to interact with them.
But do you think it is embarrassing if I say...
Nah!
Nah, people love it.
They love it.
I'm telling you they love it.
They light up or they're too polite to say otherwise.
But they love it.
I'll tell my friend what you said.
I'll make sure to tell my friend.
I'll let her know.
She's wrong.
Can I tell her?
She's stinky and wrong.
Why do I have a feeling that the friend you're talking about is in this call right now?
That's crazy, Haruka.
No, no way.
That friend is here.
No, not at all.
That would be so awful.
Yeah, I know.
I need to get into the mission.
I did it.
Yeah, they probably suck.
I'm just looking at Mint's face.
She has a smile like eyes are gone.
Why are you looking at my face, Haruka?
You want to kiss it or something?
What do you want?
I want to kiss it.
It's been, what, three years?
I haven't seen your face for three years.
I'm lonely.
Honestly, I could have gone a bit more time without seeing your face.
But here we are.
It's your fault I'm here.
I don't even understand where I screwed up in my summoning ritual.
I have no idea.
It is your fault.
It's because you were you.
It's because you just did your own thing.
You're a screw-up.
That's just the natural part.
You sound just like my mom.
Oh, sorry.
My Okasan says the same thing.
My Okan.
Mama.
I love that song.
The song they were singing earlier.
Bohemian Rhapsody?
Yes.
It is.
Okay, so I have not played this before.
What?
Oh, is it a siege?
Okay, we have to go in and we have to defend the siege.
Defend the siege.
Siege.
Come here.
Is Mint not streaming on Twitch?
Press exclamation mark Mint, it'll get you to her YouTube channel.
Sorry, I only stream on YouTube.
But if you ever watch YouTube streamers, I don't care.
How do we get into this building?
I'm going over here.
I'm here.
How do I get in?
We have to go in up top.
Okay.
I'm following you.
I'm not even sure I'm going the right way.
There should be an opening around there.
If you look in the map.
I think we went.
I'm so sorry.
I dropped us at the completely wrong place.
It's okay.
I'm so sorry.
I can't believe you would do this.
How dare you.
Mint, where...
The mission is going to start.
Blah, blah, blah.
Also, in the main missions, you just have to complete the main mission.
Even if everybody dies and the timer runs out, as long as you complete the main mission, you'll still get the score.
Come in, come in.
I have some doors to close.
Okay, wait.
I'm sorry.
We're still running.
I'm out of stamina.
Just keep running.
Okay.
There's a bug breach.
Yeah, there is a bug breach.
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to put a gatling cannon there.
Careful.
Just run.
Just run, Mint.
I'm running.
Just run and then we're going to...
And then where do we close the door?
Is this where we close the door?
Yeah, just go in first and close the door.
We run in first and then close it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Are you in this?
I think they're coming in.
Oh!
Oh, don't worry.
I got this one.
And now they're going to attack the door, so we got to...
Okay.
Oh, it's like a defense tower, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a new mission mode that they added.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Mata, go down here.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going to close this other door too.
Oh, hello.
And then we shoot them from up top.
Nice!
If you guys want to come in over here, you guys can.
Okay.
I'm throwing the bomb.
Do it.
Where's a good place to...
Oh, they broke the door because we weren't defending it.
Oh.
Oh, be careful.
Oh, my goodness.
How do I use this thing?
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
Oh, my bad.
One of you summoned me.
Sorry.
I summoned you.
I got you.
I'm shooting a bug.
I really did summon onto the wrong place.
My bad.
Sweet.
Reliver key down.
No.
It's out of bullets.
How do I get out of this thing?
Wait.
Oh, no.
I'm stuck.
Okay, guys.
We have to launch the rockets.
It looks like.
Uh-oh.
How do I get out of the way?
E?
Oh, E.
Thanks.
Thanks, chat.
We can also fall back, by the way.
If some of these are open, we can fall back.
Matara killed me, so...
I don't know what she's talking about.
Uh, I have the... I have the...
I have the facts.
Oh, it doesn't automatically.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't know what she's talking about.
It doesn't automatically.
Just protect the place.
Oh, I spawn inside of a man.
Holding doors.
Oh my god.
You're just like my momos.
That's how they are born.
Oh, I should have brought shirts.
I actually do not know what mission this is.
Oh, hello.
Oh, they closed the door on us.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
They don't love us.
It's fine.
Hey, I wouldn't need her if I was them.
Yeah, then come back here.
I don't want to see your face anymore.
We can also open it from our side.
Tascado!
How does that feel, Mint?
You love this, right?
I absolutely love it!
What the fuck?
Yeah!
Call me gross!
Call me stinky, gross, and disgusting.
Mint, I don't know you're a masochist.
Yeah, that's one of my, you know, the M in Mint.
M, M, M, M, S, S, S.
Okay.
I am doing a gatling.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I put my gatling turd now.
Oh,
good eagle.
I hope my gatling is activated.
Watch out!
Ooh!
Did I screw it up?
Did I screw up my gatling?
I think it died.
I think it got exploded.
Yeah, I accidentally screwed it up.
It had no bullets, though.
It had no bullets.
What?
I need more bullets!
More bullets!
I'm gonna go up here and I'm gonna fight.
Watch out for my laser, Fanta.
Good job, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ooh!
Wow, it's just like...
Oh, wait, I can also use laze.
Or not laze.
I have an eagle.
Wait until they start coming.
Wait until you see like that.
Look at you, you're an original.
I mean, a natural.
I'm an original.
Oh, that is smart.
Look at you.
So, if I...
You're a big natural.
Oh, oh, oh.
You're a large natural.
I'm a natural?
You're a big natural.
Then I throw it.
Yeah.
Say hello to Granati.
The way you're facing is the way you're like going down the line, basically.
Think of like your...
It's like a basketball.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Let's see.
Come here, I have ammo.
You do?
Oh, there's ammo right here.
Oh, you guys, I just had a connection error.
Oh, wait.
You can come back.
You can jump back on me from the game.
I can?
You can jump back from Steam, yeah.
Okay, okay.
I don't know what just happened.
Oh, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
Sorry, it was not me, it was Mint.
No, I know, but I can still give you a refill.
Oh, thank you.
That's so nice, you can rejoin.
Wait, so, how do I... I just from Steam?
You just right-click on Michael, Steve, and then click on join.
Okay, okay, okay.
Join the game.
And then, I don't...
Do you think your turret's gonna...
What?
How do you go, like, really far?
We can hear you.
Oh, I was gonna say, do you think your turret's gonna chance kill me at some point?
I don't know.
No, no, it's not going to.
Are the bugs coming from the other side, you guys?
By the way?
By any chance?
This is the only way?
I'm coming in!
I'm coming in hot!
I'm coming in spicy.
Come back in spicy hot.
Maybe that's a good thing.
I wonder if there's, like, a server network connection.
Papa!
Mint, you just destroyed Henya's Gatling gun!
My Gatling gun?
No!
I had the best aim ever!
You see this pad right here, Mint?
That was her Gatling gun right there.
Guys, I think the mission glitched.
You know what?
I'm fine with this.
Okay, uh, guys, they said the mission glitch is after somebody DCs.
So should we...
So we can launch the rockets.
We'll just wait it out.
How do we wait it out?
What's gonna happen?
Will any more bugs come?
I think the rocket will explode.
Right?
It'll just go.
It says rocket launch in progress, but I don't think it's launching.
How do they think it's progressing?
It doesn't automatically.
There's a bug breach, though.
The rockets shoot every two minutes.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so maybe we should be finding...
What's 612?
Okay, yeah.
Okay, will this kill me?
Yeah, they're right.
Listen, listen, there's one on the map.
Look, look, look, they're gonna launch it again.
Do you want to see what it looks like?
I could die in front of you.
Oh, I saw it.
I saw it from third person.
Oh, you did?
Good, good, good.
Do you hear that starting up sound?
Yeah, yeah.
It's about to go up.
Where are the enemies?
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
You know what?
We don't need enemies.
We don't need enemies when it's all of us.
We can just do it.
We could be each other's enemies.
What the heck?
That is so fucked up.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, I was resummoning them.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
Only in the head.
Only in all the wrong ways.
Only all the wrong ways.
Oh, but at least my suit are now clean.
Hello.
Oh, thank you.
Hello?
Hanya, be careful!
That wasn't me!
That wasn't Hanya, that was me!
No, I didn't do anything!
Kata, you killed me!
Hanya, be careful!
What the fuck?
Guys, I think we need to restart.
I don't think the rocket is going off.
I don't think so either.
It's an honor to kill my Oshii.
It's an honor.
You killed me!
Me!
Yeah, Mint.
Why did you kill her?
I kill everybody.
That's really fucked up.
I leave no prisoners.
Shaking my head, Mint.
Shaking my head, Daioh.
Shaking my head, Mint from Independent.
Shaking my head, Mint.
Mint Phantom.
It's because we have a joke.
It's usually, Shaking my head, Zen from Bishoujo.
So here it would be like, Shaking my head, Mint from Independent.
Shaking my head.
What I like to say is, Mint from Mint Fatome.
Fatome.
Sounds so fancy.
Or SMH Mint from Made Mint Channel.
Made Mint.
Don't!
That's my full name!
Only my mom can say that.
Made Mint Channel!
You're supposed to do all your homework!
No!
I want to play Pokemon more!
You better do your homework!
No!
You can't make me!
Oh, Mint!
You're going to love this one!
Why?
It's my cousin.
We're going to fight my cousin.
You're okay with killing your family?
Oh yeah!
If it was good enough for the kings in Europe, it's good enough for me.
I was so excited!
Oh yeah!
This is really fucked up!
Why is it all farting in this planet?
It's all farting!
Thank you, planet!
Thank you!
It's because it's the planet.
The planet's farting!
Yeah, the planet is making a lot of gas.
Making shit hard for us to see.
Smell.
Oh, it's not giving me a drop point.
At all.
That was really weird.
Oh, is it because of the spore towers?
Oof.
No, not the spore towers.
The spore towers can only do so much.
It's not like letting me see anything.
Can I get water real quick?
No, that's the planet.
It's a gas planet.
So that's how it's supposed to be.
I'm ready.
I'll be right back.
No, no, no, you can't.
You can't pause the game, mom.
Just guard my body.
No, no, no, you go ahead.
We'll wait.
It's no stress.
I gotta go do some job.
Go, go, go!
Well, well...
Did Henya mute us?
Nope.
Mint hasn't either.
Hey, everybody.
Do you love your oshi?
Consider gifting five gifted subs right now to them.
Do it.
Show your love while they're gone.
It's more fun to spoil them when they're not here.
That way you can't get yelled at for spoiling them.
Unless you like being yelled at for spoiling them, then spoil them when they're back.
I mean, Mint likes being yelled at.
You know who clearly doesn't love being spoiled enough?
Haruka.
Because you never freaking stream.
I literally streamed on on Sunday.
What about before that?
I had... Remember?
I streamed for our new member.
I don't remember.
Bukkwa!
Liam!
I streamed on Saturday!
Oh, oh, wait.
I think I made a mistake.
I'm getting gifted.
Please gift to Henya and Mint and Haruka.
I think you should give this sub to Mantara Khan for bringing us together for this collab.
And she's a wonderful human being.
And I'm so happy for her.
I mean, I'm not a human.
I'm a bug.
And every Monday, this is for Mint as well, her podcast.
I'm pretty bad.
It's really cool.
You all should watch her podcast.
It's so cool.
Have you?
Yeah, I watched the first episode.
I gotta watch the second and third.
And fourth, by the way.
You're behind.
I know.
I'm really behind.
I'm not kidding.
You don't have to do it.
I like to watch my friends' shit!
I love you.
You are still my friend even if you don't watch every episode.
Okay, I actually have to mute now.
Damn you all!
Now I have to mute.
You've done it.
You're welcome.
Have fun muting!
Well, well.
I have now successfully dominated all three channels at once.
Mata may have me muted, but she didn't deafen me.
So everyone can hear me.
Oh, yeah.
Hello, guys.
You guys having fun?
You having a good time?
MinceChat?
Hi, MinceChat!
I see you!
Hello!
Oh, she's back.
You know how to come?
You not streaming will not stop me.
Um, yeah.
You not streaming cannot stop me.
Welcome back!
Who the fuck are you?
I'm joking.
Your chat went crazy, Henya.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
They always do this.
Welcome back, Henya!
Welcome back!
What the heck?
Why are there so many gifs of?
I don't know!
It's Haruka's fault!
She did that!
It's her fault!
Also, Haruka also has a hype frame.
Wait, what?
It's Haruka's fault.
What?
Wait a minute.
I got an egg sandwich.
I'm streaming!
Describe taste.
A game?
What?
The fuck?
I'm typing my own offline chat.
Get out of here, guys!
Go to the people who are streaming!
Yeah, sorry.
Haruka said this thing.
Haruka said spoil your Oshi by gifting five gifted.
So that's why you probably got a lot of them.
I'm gonna let you know right now.
I don't say Oshi often.
Well, she said favorite streamer.
She doesn't say it often, but she did that once.
Wow, your impersonation is so bad.
It's true.
I hate it here.
Do you want to eat it a bit before we start?
I can let you.
I can let you finish.
I'm generous.
No, I'm good.
You sure?
I'm good!
Might be the only time.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Cool.
I care about my friend.
For every bug I kill, I'm gonna take a bite.
She's gonna snipe you.
She's gonna snipe me the moment we land.
I mean, you did every bug and you didn't specify what kind of bug.
So you're kinda fucked.
Yeah.
I like the fucking mischievous Glint.
When he said that.
Yeah, you're done-zo.
You're done-zo.
You're done.
Done-zo.
Hello everyone, this is the Zentrea planet.
Welcome.
I hope you enjoy your stay.
Oh, no wonder it's stinky though.
She's not even here.
That's why we can't even see the planet.
Oh no, Zen!
Aw, Zen from the show, Jo.
Zen from Zentrea.
Haruka, just so you're aware.
Things are happening in your stream even though you're not there.
They're still happening.
I've literally told them to fuck off to those channels.
Mint, how do you feel about flying bugs?
Oh, I like those ones.
Do you like them if they're trying to kill you?
Maybe.
I've never experienced- Nice.
Oh my god, I did that.
I'm so proud of myself.
What just got me?
Was it a flying bug?
I don't see any bugs in the air.
Oh, you know what it could be?
Mint, look at the floor.
Do you see those yellow things?
If you step on them.
Oh fuck.
What's going on?
Sorry if I hit you.
Sorry, not sorry.
Oh my god, my aim.
Not sorry.
But this thing is a Charizard, right?
Charizard, are you?
Do you see them flying in the air?
Oh yeah, I do.
I see them now.
We have to kill those little mushrooms.
That is not a bug.
That is a dinosaur.
Actually, it's a...
Oh, what the?
What?
Um...
I think...
Chris?
Yeah?
Do you want to talk about it?
Oh my god.
I think I'm dead.
You're alive.
You're fine.
It's a flesh wound.
I just started shooting.
I can resurrect you, baby.
Oh no, you've been resurrected.
I got you.
I'm not dead yet.
I'm dead.
Who was it?
Thank you, Mata.
You're welcome, baby.
I got you.
For the birds, they're going to lean down.
When they lean down, try to avoid them.
Because that's when they damage you.
Wait, two of you died.
Sorry.
Wake me up.
Wake me up inside.
I can't wake up.
If one of you comes back, and you have a stratagem, please use it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
These bugs are crazy.
I'm on fire.
If anybody has a stratagem, please.
I gotta wait for a minute.
There's three chargers, by the way.
There's a flying one, too?
Yeah, there's everything.
Oh no.
Did I gain glitch again?
It said I was killed by Hanya.
That is a crazy glitch.
Every single time.
This game is trying to set me up.
Oh my god.
Hanya, I think you're a murderer.
I don't know.
Hanya, I think you're out for blood.
Do you have murderistic tendencies?
Do you think that you want to murder?
When you see a person, do you think, I want to kill?
Oh yeah, she does.
Have you not heard her go like, kill, kill, kill.
You might be a murderer.
She is.
No, she does.
In game, in game.
Kill, kill, kill.
Where am I supposed to go?
Oh my god.
I think I'm gonna get got by a laser.
She gonna get got.
Sorry, that's my laser.
That's my laser.
Whoa, don't say that on my channel.
My viewers take that personally.
When you say my laser?
I'm so fucking sorry.
My laser?
Is it like...
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Is that better?
Yeah, so much better.
Thank you.
You know, thanks for understanding.
Wait, so I can't say the other P word?
E-N-I-S as well?
I don't know how they feel about that one, to be honest.
PP?
PP!
We can say PP, but we can't say penis?
Well, Haru!
I'm gonna get complaints.
From people being like, You're ruining Mint.
You've ruined her.
It is your fault, Haru.
I can't believe Haruku would say that.
But they're gonna somehow blame me, Haruko.
Haru, that's so fucked up that you...
I'll get blamed for this somehow.
We'll get blamed together.
I can't believe Haruka for Bishoujo cannot read the room.
It's unbelievable.
I can't believe Haruka would do this to my Mint from May Channel.
I can't believe Haruka would do this to her.
I can't believe it.
Dora, we can get blamed together.
I don't know why we're blaming people.
What's going on?
I'm shooting bugs.
Shoot them better!
I'm doing it!
We are the same.
I need a resupply.
I got you.
What?
How are you so fast?
It's coming down here.
Mint from toothpaste.
I stole that from chat.
I love reading chat's funny words and then stealing them.
I'm making two girls giggle.
These are biotines.
Yeah, they're biotines.
Mint, I want you to see it.
What's that?
Let me try and summon him.
Biotines!
Come here, biotines!
I stole your joke and they laughed.
How does it feel?
Biotines!
Mr. Biotines!
Where art thou?
Where are you?
I'm so excited to see him.
Where art thou?
Bioliet.
Oh, there he is!
Oh, wow!
Do you see him?
Zoom into him.
How do I zoom in?
Use the little scope on your gun.
Oh, yeah.
Don't look too shy.
Whoa, what do I aim for?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
I just like to tank it.
I don't...
I like to tank it, tank it.
I like to tank it.
There are so many biotines.
I mean, not biotines.
Chargers on this map.
I know.
There are so many of them.
Mags empty.
Stinky, stinky, stinky.
Hey, don't call me that.
I told you that in confidence.
I'm sorry.
I can't help, you know.
You know what, I wanna speak to this.
Your stench is just really...
Charger.
Your stench, I'm sorry.
I think you guys are smelly.
I'm inside the butt bug.
I know you said that I shouldn't say it in public, but...
I can't hold it back anymore.
When did you last shower?
Last night.
Okay.
What about you, mother?
This morning.
I don't believe you.
I know, I'm sad.
I want it to be stinky.
I went for a quick run.
So you were stinky.
Yeah, and then I showered after my run.
Why do you have to be stinky?
I like when there's a little stinky, you know?
Why?
I'm slowed.
Oh no.
A little stinky is good.
Sometimes when you're slowed and you took damage, you can stim yourself.
Oh, you can?
It's a little boost of speed.
It saves you from the snare or whatever it is.
Oh, okay.
Also, next time I'm next to you, I can give you a shield.
If you want.
But only if you want it.
It's not like you want it or anything.
I don't want your stinky shield or anything.
Fine.
You know what?
You don't deserve my big shield.
Yeah.
What is up with you and referencing Gyo and Yokio?
I think I'm going to watch that for the Patreon.
You've been referencing it like crazy recently.
I'm only referencing that one sentence.
Because I need to rewatch it to reference the other one.
What were you referencing?
Gyo and Yokio.
Gido, anime...
Huang Junxin...
I'm dead.
I'm down...
I'm deee....
DIE!
Oh yeah, she's never coming back to life.
That's so smart.
It's just like an ACR.
Oh my god.
We have a lot of chargers here.
This is... this seems like now you're in the thick of it.
Yeah, there's so many of them.
You basically have to stick with it.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I was...
In the thick of it!
Yeah!
You know what I'm referencing!
I died again.
I'm so sorry.
I got you.
I'm already summoning you back.
Oh my god, man.
Oh, I broke the rock.
Wasn't that a meme, like, long ago?
It was on the TikToks.
It was a while ago.
Yeah.
Okay, guys.
I think we need to get out of here.
It's all chargers.
There's like three of them.
I think we just have to run to the next Vile Titan.
M3, come with me.
What?
Oh, did I see you?
Yeah, just run.
Just like keep running away from here.
Oh no.
I'm getting the run out.
No!
Yeah, yeah.
I'm trying.
I'm doing that.
Oh, wait.
So actually, you know what?
No, no, no.
Stay there.
I'll revive you.
Why did you kill me, Matara?
Why did you kill me?
Because I'll just revive you in the next spot.
No way.
Away from there.
Matara!
Matara, reinforce with me now!
Reinforce me right now!
This is safer.
You reinforced to call in dead teammates.
This is safer this way.
Trust me.
Source, trust me.
See, I'm carrying you in my pocket like a Pokemon.
I'm carrying you in my pocket like a little Pokemon.
Trust me.
I don't want to be... I was caught illegally.
I was like... I was... I was taken against my will.
No!
Oh, no.
I'm in the water.
She used a Master Ball.
I didn't even have a choice.
I am drowning under the water.
You can't die.
You have to res me.
Oh, she already res you, didn't she?
No, I'm still not res.
Please, boy.
I was waiting for it to be safer.
I thought they resummoned you.
Be careful.
They will be coming soon.
Nice!
Oh, there they are.
Wait, so...
Here we go.
Yeah, there's a lot of bugs here.
We need... Oh, shit.
Oh, good one.
Oh, shit.
But, Tara from Fishojo, did you kill a maid ...
No, she launched the rocket onto herself.
Oh my ...
How did you see this shit?
I did it!
Why did our own friend from our own agency...
Mint, run from the laser.
...tell me.
Run from the laser.
I don't know what the laser is, but I'm running.
You can see it.
If you look back, you'll see it.
You'll know.
Wait, can you guys use the Command...
I can't use it.
Maybe it's on cooldown?
No, I can't even see them.
Oh my god.
Why are there so many bugs on this map compared to the other ones?
Did I accidentally put a... I don't think I have a clue.
We are on hard mode or what is going on?
We were on 5 for the last 3 missions.
I saw that.
Min, just keep running.
Okay, I'm running.
I'm gonna run towards everybody.
Oh no, he's catching up to me.
Run towards him.
When he comes at you, you can jump to the side when he's real close to you.
When you're running, try to look back a bit.
You can outrun most bugs.
You can?
Yeah, except the little white ones.
If they're in a group, you usually should have to turn around to kill the little white ones.
Oh god, just run.
Yeah, just run.
You're doing great.
Oh boy.
Oh gosh.
Just run towards them.
And they'll be able to assist us.
Wow, I still jumped out of his way, but he...
I got you.
Thank you.
I'm running.
Oh, he's right...
You're gonna be able to assist us.
Friendship door here.
Oh, there's a guy in front.
Nice.
There's a guy in front.
Okay, there's a guy behind too.
Careful, Min.
There's a guy behind you.
Yeah.
Oh.
What?
Okay.
Woo!
See, like sometimes it's easy and then you get into a difficulty and you're like, oh my god.
Oh my god, indeed.
Okay.
That blew up, yes.
Now for the other ones.
Okay.
These little white ones that you usually cannot run.
Oh, they're fast?
Yeah.
If they're in a group, yeah, they'll jump on you and stagger you.
Oh shoot.
But the rest of them, you can outrun them.
Oh my god, reloading is gonna kill me.
I just like to take a breathe.
Oh my god.
Freedom.
They taste like mint, I think.
What?
Freedom tastes like mint?
Yeah.
And toothpaste.
To the best!
For prosperity!
Uh-oh.
Prosperity awaits in the care of magnets.
Honestly.
What the?
Did you not read the company policy?
Thank you, Daniel!
I didn't know!
Now wave as you stay in autonomy.
I just threw something and I'm not sure what.
Don't worry, Hany, I got you back.
Sorry.
I think I know what you just threw.
I don't think that was me.
Uh-huh.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
Samples.
Democracy.
Let's go.
Nice!
Do you have, um...
Oh, I'll just use this gun.
Let's do more.
Should we go towards them?
Yeah, go towards them.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna kill this guy so he doesn't follow us.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
I got this set.
I'm running.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I'll let you know when it beeps.
Yes!
I'm running.
Okay.
Running, running.
Oh, careful.
Men to your left are bugs.
Stop!
Is that good?
Yeah, if you heard the beep sound, it means that it's in line.
Maybe they're at your other left?
Yeah.
I'm killing some.
Go back, go back, go back, go back, go back, go back.
Stop!
Okay.
Yeah, so if you hear the beep...
Yeah, getting a lot of chargers is hard when you don't have, like, the items to kill them.
So, Hany, there's, like, a distinct beep sound coming from the terminal that lets you know that, um, you aligned it perfectly.
Oh, really?
Yeah, so that's why sometimes it's easy to do this on your own if you can.
Here they come.
Oh!
I see.
Thank you.
Oh, I see.
Oh, yeah.
How's that?
Refill.
That's empty.
Yeah!
All right, girls.
I will awaken...
The beast?
The beast within.
I will awaken the beast within.
Are you gonna wake a state... or a bomb?
Oh, my God.
I don't have a laser, but I'm gonna do what I can.
Don't tell me that I'm gonna miss him.
Okay, it still hit him.
Thank God.
I'm in my own world, you guys.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's him again.
Uh-oh.
Oh, he's throwing up!
We're in the middle of two...
We're in the middle of two bug breaches.
Uh-oh.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
So we gotta go back towards them?
Or yeah, you're towards them.
Perfect.
I was in the middle of two bug breaches.
Nick was doing great.
No!
I got you, Hanya.
I got you.
No, I got her.
I got her.
Throw.
Oh, God.
I'm sorry.
I put you in a pretty bad spot.
I'm okay.
My dad didn't kill me.
I almost had him killed.
I just needed to do one more Kusar cannon and he's dead.
Yeah.
I need ammo.
There we go.
Good job.
Beautifully done.
I don't think I shot out of my Haruka from Bishoujo.
That's my gamer girl.
That's my Canadian moose.
That's my girl.
What?
You're gonna burn me?
Run, run, run.
I will burn myself to a crisp.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
I got you.
Thank you.
Nice.
Oh.
Never mind.
I fucking suck.
You can go back and pull back.
Being in the sand.
Oh, he's dead now.
You know what?
I can still see the control.
God dang it.
You still can't see the...
Oh.
I've done that before.
Wait.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
I don't know how I turned it back.
Is anybody in your chat?
I feel like they have to see it.
I know I've done that before.
I know the bug you're talking about.
I need that too.
I think it's usually when you have your map open.
Oh, my God.
When you have your map open, you like can't...
Yeah.
Press tab again.
Oh, I did.
But it still doesn't work.
Don't do that.
Oh, shit.
Man.
What?
Why didn't you tell me you were so...
Maybe if I finish the mission, it'll be fine.
Why do you need to know?
It's my fault.
So, what are you trying to do?
Are you trying to open up your stratagem, Senya?
Huh?
If I walked into it, it was going to kill me.
So, what are you trying to do?
I'm looking at your stream now.
Are you trying to open your...
Pay attention.
Oh, I'm trying to...
I'm pressing the control right now.
But it doesn't see like...
Usually, they show me the like a stuff, right?
The arrow stuff.
But I can't see it.
Hmm.
Rare...
Oh.
Oh, no.
Let's eat.
I'm going to turn around.
That is weird.
I think that's okay.
No.
We got him.
Okay.
If you can see the bait, I can get him with this gun.
If I am the bait, you said?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm good at that.
I think you'll be fine if we leave this mission, maybe?
Yeah.
I think that's it.
See?
He's dead.
Maybe just in this mission.
Oh, nice.
Good job.
I didn't do anything.
You're the bait.
I know.
But you still helped.
You were the bait.
I'm going to survive.
You had a very important job.
That's true.
You were the bait.
I was delicious.
Minty freshness.
Over here.
You want a little bite of a...
Oh, gee.
You mind?
Maybe that'll work.
Minty girl.
A little bite of a what?
Hey there, big bug.
You want a little bite?
What's this?
Can I open it?
There's a chair.
Anyone want to sit?
You can try.
Okay.
I got you.
It ain't working.
I'm trying.
Oh.
She did it.
She fixed your problem.
I love her.
I probably should reload.
And...
What?
Are you going to kill us, Mint?
I'm talking to the little guys.
Wait.
I thought we fought over this democracy thing all along.
I'm killing the little guys.
I don't want to...
If you're a little guy, run.
Run because you are in trouble right now.
Uh-oh.
She will kill you.
Oh.
Yeah.
Let my red thing go and then...
Oh.
Sorry.
Matara.
Um.
Why did you not tell me that you were launching some missiles?
Matara.
I died.
Honestly.
To be completely honest with you, it's my fault.
I just thought you saw the big red thing in front of you.
My bad.
Matara.
You really overestimated how good my vision is.
Okay?
You're right.
I too am blind and old.
Well, you're not old, but you're blind.
Definitely the blind part.
Yeah.
All
right.
I'm coming in.
I
guess so.
It was so like matter of fact.
Like, yup.
That's it.
That's it?
Yeah.
We're just...
Yup.
We're gaming, Haruka.
We're gaming.
We are.
We can't...
Minch, have you been to Little Seas?
We're gaming right now.
We were talking about that earlier.
Yeah.
I have been to...
I used to...
Yeah.
I...
You used to what?
No.
Nothing.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh.
Well, I would...
So, I would go with friends.
Uh-huh.
But...
Okay.
She's bragging.
She has friends.
Yeah.
I have friends.
I don't have any friends.
What the fuck?
You too.
Minch, back out.
Minch, back up.
You were too.
You didn't want me fast enough.
What the fuck?
You got a point.
I'm...
I'm slow.
You got a point.
I'm gonna go right on top of you.
She just got something recently, okay?
She's trying to get everything back.
Yeah.
God.
Get everything.
Get back.
Oh, my God.
I can't even get my stuff back because you killed me.
Yeah, you can.
Where is it?
I'm stuck.
Let us go to the charger and then you're gonna go get your stuff, okay?
Okay.
I'm gonna get...
I'm gonna get hit by the charger.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I'm actually stuck.
Oh, no, no, no.
Wait.
I'm actually stuck.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
It's a good thing you didn't get your stuff then because then you'll die again and you'll get your stuff after.
No.
He's just staring at me.
I got him.
I got his butt.
Okay.
Let me...
Oh, people are saying dive.
Oh.
Okay.
Get up now.
No, run.
Oh.
Thanks, guys.
Run.
Thanks.
I was safer.
I was safer being there to be honest.
I think so too because I was shooting his butt.
Yeah.
I was distracting him.
We're pretty good.
We're gaming now.
I wonder what those two are up to.
I think they're fine.
Yeah.
We're gaming.
We're doing good.
Yeah.
Are you still alive?
Yep.
I'm still alive.
Oh.
Hey.
I got you.
Thank you.
You're alive.
Here.
Come here.
I don't know how long I'll be alive for, to be honest.
You're alive forever.
Don't worry, baby girl.
I got to make sure my bitch, Henya, stays alive.
Oh, sorry.
I got to make sure my tongue, Henya, stays alive.
You're getting acquainted.
I'm learning.
I'm learning a lot.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
Uh-oh.
Do you have a second gun?
Press number two?
Yeah, but it's not good.
Not yet.
Okay.
Got it.
It's better than mine.
Okay.
All right.
Let's go towards them, then.
Actually, no.
This is where we evacuate.
Oh, yeah.
No.
Let's go towards them.
That's where we...
Just run.
Why am I so slow?
I think I'm going to die.
I think I'm...
Just run.
I'm...
I am...
I'm doing the best that I...
Oh.
The little bitch that could...
Why am I so fucking close to the bitch?
Yeah.
Oh.
Hey.
Get out of my bag.
Oh, it's the little...
A white one's done.
Yeah.
There are so many of us.
Oh, my gosh.
I am...
Min can come to us closer now.
I had no more stims, you guys.
I had no more stims.
Run.
Run to them.
I'm going to clear the little box.
No.
I'm dead.
Oh.
Okay.
No.
Maka, the ship is down already.
We're waiting for everyone to come here.
Yeah.
We're waiting for you guys to come.
Well, yeah.
We're trying.
Oh, this is water.
This is water.
No comment.
Sorry.
This is water.
You guys are over there.
In case of making out, we're hanging out with the victims of democracy.
I got you.
Now we have only seven reinforcements.
I think we're here.
I think we're doing a really good job.
Right, Mata?
I think we are too.
Keep going.
We're gaming.
And then to the left?
And then...
Oh, to the left.
Oh.
No, to the left.
Oh, my God.
What is this?
Was that you?
No.
Guys, you should summon her next to you.
Summon her where you are.
And I'll run.
Cut my head off.
Oh, God.
Cut my head in two pieces.
I can't read his voice.
My game is off.
Yeah.
I think she meant the other left, you guys.
Oh.
Here I come.
I'm coming.
Wait for me.
Guys, just get in the car.
No, no, because then it'll leave.
Now you guys can leave.
I think it lowers our experience.
Wait!
It lowers our experience, but it's fine.
My samples!
Sorry, Haru.
Sometimes I just start killing the bugs and not looking at the mission.
I'm reloading.
So you guys should've just been like, oh guys, we're at the end.
We're doing the... because we were just having fun.
Do you see why I invited Haruka to this collab?
Because she actually gets the shit done.
I... wait, it bugged?
Wait, some people said you died.
No, it didn't.
It didn't bug.
No, no, Kenya had the stratagem glitch, so she couldn't put down any stratagems.
Oh, yeah, wait.
Oh, I made it!
Yippee!
Wait, why did I...
How are you the only one?
I don't know.
Huh?
I left them behind.
Did you get into the ship?
Did you actually run into the ship?
Maybe on accident, but I don't know.
Mince.
Honestly, pretty bait.
Shaking my head.
Hey, this is my first time playing this game, okay?
Oh, the ship got damaged?
The shuttle extraction bug?
Oh...
Wait, if the ship get damaged, they will start the ship?
I think I was trying to get away from a bug and I dove into the ship.
That's pretty bait.
Dun dun dun dun.
Yippee!
I cannot believe it, Mince.
You ruined everything.
I got to the ship!
I made it alive!
You ruined everything.
I did it.
Everything I ever loved, everything I ever worked for.
How the fuck did Matora Khan not die a single time?
That's crazy.
Yo, it's called gaming.
He didn't die a single time?
Bada bam, bada bing, bada boom.
Bada boom.
I thought you're not supposed to have capes.
Um, Mince, we are hell divers.
It's a requirement to have a cape.
I'm sorry, yeah.
It's not that we're superheroes we're not supposed to have a cape.
Listen, Mince, not wearing a cape is the most least democratic thing we can do.
Oh, true, true, true.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
True, true, true.
Are we not superheroes, you guys?
It's a superhero rule, but are we not superheroes?
We are protecting, we are bringing democracy.
Is that not a superhero thing?
Bada bing, bada boom.
My headphones cut out.
Can you re-say that whole thing?
I said bada bing, bada bam.
Bam, bam, bam.
Bada bang, bam, bing.
Bada bing, bada boom.
Bing, bing, bong.
Bing, bing, bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong.
Bing, bong, bing, bong, bing, bong.
Here, I'll translate for you.
Mince, say your thing.
I'll translate.
Bada bam, bing, bong, bing, bing, bong.
So she said that are we not superheroes because we're spreading democracy because we have kids?
Are we not superheroes?
That's basically what she said.
Yeah.
I think we're going crazy.
I think so, too.
I don't know what's happening.
I blame him, yeah.
I'm speaking my truth.
Wah, wah, wah.
Say it from your chest.
Say it with your balls, Mint.
What am I saying?
Your truth.
Bing, bing, bong, bing.
Bing, bing, bong.
Bing, bing, bong, bing, bong.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bong.
You know what?
It's very rare when the second season of an anime is better than the first one.
Wait, guys, I'm going to re-join the game.
My game is still glitched.
Oh wait, why did I?
Oh no, I spawned in the worst place.
Oh god.
But why did you already?
It's not very often that the second season of an anime's OP is better than the first one, really.
What is that from?
I just know the song.
It's from Mastral.
Yeah, Machiru, Machiru.
It's really funny.
It's basically if one punch man goes to a wizard school.
So basically, he's born without any magic and he has to punch his way.
And people are like, oh my god, that was his magical power!
It's really fucking funny.
It's just punching?
I like that.
That is pretty magic.
I don't want to spoil that.
I don't want to spoil the first episode because it's really fucking funny.
So please watch Mastral.
No spoilers!
I watched the first episode!
It was fun!
Yes!
I need to finish season 2.
That is not a person.
I don't like it.
I'm okay.
I'm alright.
Also, Mint, this is not your eyes.
This is just...
I feel like I'm playing Metal Gear Solid 3 right now.
Oh no, this is what it's going to look like?
Yeah, it's just...
It's because there's a spore spawner.
Oh, I died.
Not anymore.
Come back.
War never ends.
Rise!
Summon me again!
MATARO KON!
Out of the atmosphere, I gotta disappear.
Fuck.
I'm stuck.
There's a spore mushroom that I see.
Oh my god, these guys in the sky?
Oh, what?
They're not dead yet?
It's a bird, it's a plane, it's a guy.
Oh, jeez.
There's...
How...
How the hell...
There we go.
Oh, good job, Haruka.
See, this is why I brought Haruka.
We needed a gamer.
Gamer!
You are so annoying!
I just played a game.
Oh my god.
No.
Oh, you just played?
God!
Oh god!
Oh gosh.
Why are there so many of them?
Wrong way!
Oh, there you go.
It's fixed.
Nice.
Good job.
Alright.
Haruka carry.
That's our girl.
Where is everybody?
Hiding from you.
I get that.
Hiding my way from you.
No.
Don't turn your back.
Wanna be a professional.
I'm so into you.
Oh my god.
Let me take...
I cannot aim for these birds.
I know.
They suck.
The one sucks.
He's nuts.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Little guy.
I will now graduate.
This is the only peak humor I can do.
My ears bleeding.
From the...
From the joke or the what?
It's a gift, Tenya, from me to you.
Thank you for the gift, Tenya.
Bullshit!
You're welcome.
Oh my gosh.
Freedom never sleeps!
So I did not mean to say shit on your stream, Mint, but fuck, I am about to die.
That's okay.
I say... I accidentally say bad things too sometimes.
Mint casually bites the center nose.
Haruka is about to...
...breathe her last breath today.
Oh shit.
Oh, I see I said it too on accident.
Oh, I'm out of ammo on everything.
You said those words?
It's okay, Mint.
I got you.
You do?
Death note?
Where are you?
Well, I mean, I got the charger.
Oh.
Well, there was another charger.
Oh!
I got the guy!
What the fuck are you...
I like how you said that.
That was actually very cute.
Not that I can.
Not that I can!
That was very cute.
I kinda liked it.
Oh yeah, I gotta get...
Oh, wait.
I was angry.
I have this gun that like, shoots lasers.
But if friendly people are in the line of fire, it...
Also, shoots the friendly people.
Yeah.
That's a funny thing that is.
It's very fun.
That's why I use it.
That's fucked up, LaTara!
There's everybody here.
Oh!
Not me.
They have a taste of democracy.
Wait, is that the ARC gun?
Yeah, the ARC rifle.
I love it.
I'm reloading.
Don't reload it when the bugs are right by you.
I didn't realize that it was going to be that kind of reload.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, the machine gun has that.
I didn't realize.
Alright, let's go do the side mission.
We're here.
Let's do it.
Okay!
For science!
I don't think I've done this one before.
I don't even know where to go.
What are we doing?
I don't know.
I'm trying to find it.
Science!
We should look for a computer.
A computer!
Okay.
But I don't see a computer.
I'm going to go destroy X.
Good girl.
X.
Oh, it's the hell bomb.
Hell bomb?
We don't have the hell bomb though.
You have to call in a hell bomb near the grey building.
You sent us on a wild goose chase.
We're already here.
Oh, I see it.
Okay, mint?
Yeah.
Run.
Run far.
Oh hey, you're here with me, Dayo.
Yeah, I'm here, Dayo.
I came here.
For you.
You're like, I'm just getting killed by Matara two times.
I'm here.
What did you do?
Why did you do that?
Sorry.
To be honest, I didn't think you were going to die.
My bad.
Watch out, Hanyang.
Did I mess up the hell bomb?
Okay, okay.
I'm leaving.
Yeah, you deserve that.
You deserve to mess it up.
Where are you?
I'm going to land right on your head.
Did I mess up the hell bomb?
You messed up everything, Matara!
What's going on there?
Oh, I had to punch in the code in the hell bomb.
Fudge.
Okay, I'm sorry, mint.
This is why I brought Haruka, because I don't know how to do anything.
Yeah, I can tell.
Where's the bomb?
So you have to go back inside and...
Yeah, I think I have to like activate the code on it.
Hanyang, be careful.
I'm going to throw it.
Okay.
I'm running.
What?
I just have to find where I put it.
Where did I...
Guys, do you know where I summoned the bomb?
I'm going to run the other way.
Oh, you missed.
Oh, I missed.
Did you throw it?
Oh, thank you.
Did you do it?
I'm about to do it.
I think I'm going to go to where Hanyang and Haruka are.
Sounds good.
I think we should do that.
Nice, we did it.
There's a bug nest here if you want to do it.
Nice teamwork.
I don't want to do anything with you.
Oh my god.
I'm not there to win this game.
What the fuck?
Fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight, fight.
Yee-haw.
Let's go.
I'm going to refill my supply pack.
Don't be anywhere near the bomb.
Oh, you put the bomb?
Yeah.
I put the bomb all right.
Oh.
Yippee.
Oh my god, there's a corner right there.
Where'd she go?
Oh, here.
Uh-oh.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
I love you.
Not today.
I'm sorry, but you got to be careful.
I'm going to use my laser right now.
What did I...
What did I miss?
What is it that I missed?
So, I put...
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize you were very close to me.
Uh-huh.
I killed myself.
So, I had summoned, like, my rock.
Oh, my god.
I'm about to die.
I was trying to kill the nest with my rock.
It's my fault.
Let me give you a shield.
It's going to help.
No.
What?
I'm sorry.
What was she doing?
What?
I thought you were going to kill me.
You're not supposed to...
I'm going to resummon you.
Okay.
We just...
I killed it.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck now?
Thanks.
Oh, shit.
You're fucked.
All right.
Let's go towards...
Big red laser equals splat.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I can still remember back.
It's okay.
Okay.
I got this.
I just got this.
Thank you.
I'm here now.
You got this.
I believe in you.
We're here.
We're close-ish.
Oh.
We're kind of close.
We're pretty far, but it's fine.
It's fun to run.
No.
I can see them fighting.
Thank you.
The girls are fighting.
The bitches are shitting.
Yay.
Oh, yeah.
Have you ever heard of that one?
Are you a girl that poops or a bitch that shits?
Are you a bitch that shits?
What?
It's like, are you a girl failure or a girl boss kind of vibe?
I am a bitch that shits.
I think I'm a girl boss, but my chat thinks I think is a girl failure.
You know what?
I'm inclined to agree, to an extent.
I think you're a little girl failure.
What do you mean by that, Haruka?
What do you mean by that?
Yeah, Haruka.
You still look kind of suggestive.
I think someone should hold your hand sometimes, like right now.
I think she wants to hold your hand, Min.
I want to hold yours.
Awww.
I don't want to be an American.
And freeze.
I need you to take care of the butt man.
What about if I died?
It's okay.
You didn't die because I fresh-bent.
Oh thank you.
I'm on his butt.
I'm ready.
To distract him.
I don't want to be an American idiot.
Oh that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Oh that's weird.
Shut up.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
You're okay.
You're fine.
There's some guys behind you.
Yeah I see.
Let me get the little guys behind you.
You just keep running away girl.
Oh there's a bug breed.
We should actually just run to them.
Let's run to them.
Run to them.
He's like missing a leg.
Oh my god.
Please.
Idiot.
Dummy.
Stupid.
Stinky.
Did I go too far?
Did I go too far again?
I think you're doing fine.
Go towards them.
I'm really sorry.
I didn't mean to.
I take it back.
I regret my words and actions.
What did she say?
She said that you stink.
Hi guys.
I'm here.
Yes.
By the way, we haven't done the main mission yet.
We've just been running around being little silly goofy girls.
I've been doing the main mission.
Have you done any of the main mission?
I don't think so.
I've done a ton.
We're getting together.
Yeah.
I also was here.
I came in like a little later.
You were here for the emotional support.
Yeah.
I was.
I showed up.
I killed an egg.
I helped.
Shit, shit, shit.
You see that eagle?
Run, run, run.
I think you should go towards it.
Henya, you tried.
Surprise!
Happy birthday!
Oh, it was Henya.
Oh, she eagled you.
I didn't get eagled.
I mean, she tried to kill you.
I'm happy about it.
See, I told you.
We're on difficulty five.
I think you underestimate my degeneracy.
Oh, I definitely don't.
I'm gonna get the bug nest.
Actually, Haru, I might need assistance.
I only have a few grenades.
This is a really big one.
I have one grenade.
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm getting my resupplies real quick.
You already summoned the resupplies?
Are you okay?
I did.
Can somebody punch me?
I don't know what I'm gonna do.
What the heck?
This is a big bug nest.
Like, it's good experience.
I didn't know!
Wait, you're inside the rock?
What the fuck?
Oh, yeah, it's a bug.
I'll blow up the rock.
Do it, do it, do it.
Okay, okay.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, hold on.
I gotta make sure I don't die.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, don't die, don't die.
You're in the rock.
Yeah, there's no way we can get you out of there.
Blow up the rock!
That's one way to save her.
What the fuck, my bug?
Haru, Haru, Haru, come, come, come.
There's a big bug nest, but I don't have any grenades.
I have grenades.
There's a huge bug nest.
Like, eight holes left.
Yeah, but this is two and there's like eight holes left, I think.
Well, you know what?
I'm good at filling holes.
I need your help.
Where is it?
You'll see, you'll see.
We're going to...
Where the bugs are coming from is where it is.
Oh, oh my goodness.
Oh my god, you speak Momo?
Does that how Momo speak?
That's Momo speak.
You speak Momo.
Fire in the hole!
You know what?
I can't aim!
I quit!
Oh my goodness.
It's all Min's fault.
It's my fault?
Yeah, it's all your fault.
You bitch.
She's happy to be the little villain.
Yeah, Min speaks your language.
That is so cute.
Is that it?
Oh, I see it.
The steam's coming up.
Yep, that's the hole you need to get rid of.
If I throw it from here, you think it'll reach?
What's the worst that can happen?
You missed?
I think I missed.
Hold on.
Oh, Min.
You got this, Min.
I believe in you.
I got it!
Good job, Min!
Good job, girlies.
We have 23 minutes left.
Let's, uh...
Let's remove...
as my grandparents used to say.
How do I tag the map again?
Can you remind me, Haruka?
Hold tab, and then you hold right click.
Oh, it's hold right click.
There we go.
You hold right click to move your mouse.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna get some more ammo.
Oh, yeah?
Okay.
I'm coming.
Yeah.
Haru?
Can we get the ammo?
Oh, I already called it.
You already used all of it?
Me?
Oh.
Or you mean it didn't come down yet?
No, I just called it.
Haru, if you have your backpack, if she gets it, then we get one more.
It's a little hack.
It's a little gamer trick.
Oh, my gosh.
Why am I always climbing?
Oh, my God.
Leave me alone.
Yeah, I dropped it.
They're down here.
You see them?
Are you far?
Is there a ping?
How do you ping in this game?
Q.
You're a cutie.
Oh, my God.
You need to stop it right now.
Let's run to the other eggs.
I have the Riz.
He is the Riz.
Riz.
Do you have any Riz mint?
Some would say yeah.
I like how Mata literally calls you out by laughing like that.
I would say yes.
My mom?
What are you talking about?
Why are you flirting with your mom?
Okay, Oedipus.
Oedipus?
I don't know how to say his name.
Oedipus.
Why do you think making fun of somebody whose native language is in English is funny?
It's not even English.
Sorry.
You're getting cancelled.
I'm writing my tweet right now.
One second.
I'm writing my cancellation.
I'm writing my cancellation right now.
It's Greek.
I know.
Hold on.
Wait a minute.
I have to do this to me.
Mint.
Come over here and look at this and tell me what it looks like.
It looks like a little onion.
It looks like a bunch of onions.
Yeah.
Onions.
A bunch of big onions.
Aw, shit.
The bugs are coming.
Oh, shit.
Oh, he missed me.
You know what, Mint?
This is me writing out my tweet longer right now.
I can't even.
What are you doing?
Where are you?
I can't even hear you over the bugs.
I'll wipe water for you.
I can't believe we do something like this.
Unbelievable.
What a terrible person and tweet.
What the fuck?
Oh, thank you.
We should run though.
There's a few chargers.
And charge these nuts.
You said it.
Where did I die?
Over there.
You died like right over there.
You can see it on your map.
No, I know.
I just always say it out loud.
Oh, smart.
You know in puzzle games when you're like, what would I do if I was this?
And then somebody gives you the solution.
You're like, no, no, I'm just thinking out loud.
Oh, wait, that's my body.
No, I totally get it.
I'm like, hey chat, here's the signal for you to ask questions.
I'm like, hey chat, blah, blah, blah.
Yeah.
It doesn't work though.
It doesn't work?
They never read.
You can have like no spoilers.
They never read what I'm speaking out of my mouth.
They won't listen.
They can't read my lips.
Read my lips.
Words are hard.
Listening is harder.
I don't know.
I think the wisps are pretty good.
Oh yeah?
We'll see about that.
Play a puzzle game.
I dare you.
I have.
We played Doom Beans.
You know what you should do?
I play a game with my friend called Escape Room Similar.
Oh yeah, I've heard of that one.
Oh, I heard about that before.
I heard about that.
That's a great puzzler if you want to put your brain to the test.
Oh, that's a puzzle game.
Yeah, because it's like you're trying to escape from the room.
There's a bunch of puzzles for you to solve.
And I don't know why I can't go through.
Where are we going?
Giga and I played one of those.
It was so funny.
Oh, really?
Like those whatever, like we were here together type of vibes.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, the bugs are here.
Oh, we are here.
I love that game.
The bugs are here.
Where are the bugs?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Hi.
I don't know why these bugs remind me of my cat.
Why?
I don't know.
The way they crawl at me reminds me of my cat.
I think.
Are you saying your cat is a fucking demon from the hells?
Maybe.
Well, like cat like owner.
You know?
Are you a demon?
That means I raised him well.
You know they have those pictures of dogs that start looking like their owners?
Oh yeah.
If Mint's cat is misbehaving, you know why.
Hey everyone.
I'm going to open the extraction point.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
Yeah, let's run to the extraction.
Mint, run towards me.
Run towards me, I can help.
Where is it?
It's behind you.
It's at the opposite side.
You can re-summon your stuff at the extraction point.
Oh, he killed himself.
They have a cooldown, right?
Thank you, thank you.
If you look right now, your stuff is going to have a cooldown.
Oh yeah, I can call them.
Yeah, you can call them again.
Usually what we do, as soon as you get to the...
Oh my god.
Not only playing Risk of Rain 2.
Of course he is.
Go to the blue.
And go to the blue.
My drone.
Blue, blue, blue.
We're going to the blue.
Do that!
Bienvenido, yummy, yummy.
Yummy, yummy.
Thank you, thank you.
One minute, one minute.
One minute.
Doing good, doing good.
Yeah, he just kind of looks like my cat.
When he does that.
I cannot wait to be the judge of that.
That's your...
Wait, that's your cat attack you like that?
No.
Why not?
Forkway, no.
I mean, sometimes.
I like how you've been saying Forkway because of me all the time.
I feel like I stole that one from you, yeah.
Yeah, that was Forkway.
But Fajitas de Polo was mine.
I've had that one.
That's been mine since forever.
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
Forkway, no.
Fajitas de Polo is mine and only mine.
I'm the only person...
Whoa!
Oh, nice kill!
Ah!
Hey, oh, sorry, man.
I should have warned you that was Flying Eagle.
That's okay.
I'm used to it by now because I'm a...
Oh, because of what?
Yeah, you heard me.
Because I'm a Tarakhan!
Uh-oh.
Yeah, you heard me.
I'm landing!
Uh-oh.
Can everybody get to the shuttle?
Which is fine?
I'm on my way!
Ouch!
Oh, uh...
Uh-oh.
Uh...
Anyone wanna res me?
No!
No, I mean, I've got your samples, which is more important than your life, but that's all right!
Oh, actually, I was concerned about the samples, so, you know...
Yeah, I got the samples.
Samples, everything.
It's okay because I left you guys last time.
Yeah, you kinda ditched us.
Now it's, uh...
Now it's...
It's even.
And we're all best buddies for it, you know?
I got you guys!
You guys got me!
No, no, no.
Who are you?
Oh my gosh, I love you guys!
Oh my gosh!
I'm sorry, Mint, we have to kick you out.
I think Maus is coming online, so we want to make it...
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Do you know this Mint person?
No, no.
She's been, like...
following me around ever since I summoned her.
No, I mean, like...
I mean, like...
I mean...
Yeah.
This is so great, we're just one big happy family, you know?
You're not a part of this family.
Look, I'm also in this picture!
There's also me too!
Your hand's popping out!
That's so funny!
Haru, did you teach her how to buy guns and stuff?
Yeah.
Should we teach her so she tries different guns?
No, I can't afford them.
What about stratagems?
If you come where I am?
No, I know.
I bought the eagle.
Okay, you can buy more stuff.
I don't have enough money!
Oh wait, yes I do now.
You have enough money for chicken nuggets.
Holy shit, I kinda want chicken nuggets.
Is the stalwart good?
Buy everything and then try them out.
Try every gun?
I only have 9000.
Oh yeah, you'll get more as we keep playing.
Okay.
My wife asked me to stop singing Wonderwall to her.
The stalwart is good?
I said, maybe.
Okay.
I like that.
Arc time!
Henya's about to be out for murder.
Yeah, I'm going for Arc Dio.
Arc Dio.
Oh, this is a 12 minute mission.
So this one we gotta go fast.
Yeah, Mata.
You don't think she knows about the R menu?
Make sure we gotta go fast.
Mintzchat, has she been using R to buy guns?
What do you mean R to buy guns?
If you go into R.
Oh yeah, what do you mean R?
And then you go into Warbon, you see R?
Press R.
R.
Do you see it says Helldivers, mobilize.
Do you see that?
Yeah.
Okay, and now you can buy the guns in there.
Yeah, don't forget that!
I think if you keep going down, the gun that I'm using, it's on page 5 out of 8, it's called the Sight.
What did I get?
I really like it.
I usually try to get the guns, the grenade, and the super credit.
Oh wait, I think I bought something on accident when I meant to... wait.
That's fine.
I thought...
So it's a battle pass, so basically you have to unlock some of the pages when you move down a page.
Basically.
So you didn't technically fuck off, you have to unlock the other things.
Oh, I see, okay, I thought I was redeeming...
Oh my god, this is...
What's this thing?
A super credit?
I can't see... oh.
So super credits is like in-game currency, but you can find that shit in the overworld and get them from the battle pass too.
So it's super free to play friendly.
Nice!
Yeah, you just have to play a lot.
What's this one?
Yeah, it's not like...
141 hours of this game.
What's the...
What's the grenade that launches immediately?
Oh, that's called the high impact grenade and that's in several pages down.
I think I got the grenade.
I believe in you.
Oh, wait.
The game is always free to play.
You can even collect super credits in-game.
Like, if you play a lot of hours, you don't have to spend money.
I mean, yeah, you spend money to buy the game for sure, but buying like the...
Yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Gotta spend money for games.
How do I...
Oh, that's what you meant.
You have to buy the game.
Okay, okay.
Sometimes I've seen people come in chat be like, oh, is the game free on random games?
I'm like, why do you think it would be free?
Why do you think it would be free?
It could be.
I don't know.
It could be, but why?
Wait, how do I change my...
How do I change my weapon and stuff?
Oh, we have to...
Oh, okay.
Come here.
Actually, you can change it during the mission, but if you come to this computer right here, and then you go into...
Two is armory, and then character, booster, you can like see everything.
So you can go into armory and then change your armor, change your stuff.
Oh, oh.
Try this one.
Is it equipped?
You know what else you can change?
Everything.
Deez nuts.
She's gone.
We lost her.
Wait, but this one...
Oh, I guess this one has a longer fuse time.
Okay.
I kind of look like a bug.
Ooh.
Oh my god, my face.
Oh yeah, Haru, what time did you go to sleep today?
I don't think you really want to know.
Yeah, I do.
Is it 4pm?
Wait, where's the other gun that I got?
No, it was 1pm.
Do I have to order that one?
Some of the other guns, you have to order, like...
You know in game when you can put a gun to use, that you summon from the big crates?
Some of the guns you summon from the big crates.
So there's your primary weapon, which is like your regular gun.
Secondary weapon, which is like a little revolver.
And then you summon special guns.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I figured the special gun.
I figured, yeah.
So the special guns, it just depends what you like to do.
Okay.
For me, I hate ammo, so I always try to get guns that don't use ammo.
Wait, where's my other emote?
Oh wait, here we go.
I ate it.
That's the most evil laugh I've ever heard from you, and I'm terrified for my life.
No, I've heard more emote.
But I go to bed tonight, and if I have a sleep paralysis, and I hear that evil laughter, I know it's too late.
I'm the sleep paralysis demon!
Coming to visit you.
Rah!
Wait, so are you a demon now or are you a ghost?
My sleep paralysis ghost can't be back to you.
No, I'm a ghost, I'm a ghost.
What?
Yeah, I was very confused.
Mata, your ritual was disturbing.
I don't know what I messed up in it, genuinely.
Okay, this mission is fast.
12 minutes.
We go in, we kill, we get out.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Boom.
I already forgot.
I already put the microwave on fire.
What are we doing?
We all scratched at once.
Instructions unclear.
I already blew up the house.
What do these do?
I don't know.
I don't know why that reminded me of that song.
I still have this game audio turned off.
Mint, you're getting it.
You get the vibe.
I think, I don't know.
It's still fun though.
Here we go.
Oh, yeah.
You get it, you get it.
That's our girl.
Run towards the red stuff, because that's where the holes are.
Close as many holes as you can.
Okay.
You know what else we can close the hole with?
A gun.
What?
You thought I was going to say these stuff.
No, I was not.
I can't believe you thought.
What?
I don't even see red on the map.
I don't see it too.
Yeah, because it's sort of blocked off.
So the shitty thing about this gas.
It covers up the compass.
So we don't get to see anything.
So just run until you find a bus hole.
There's a friend by ourselves.
He's asleep.
Don't let him wake up.
Yeah, take that.
With the green bugs.
What's their place to shoot them in?
The face as well.
Because they're armored nursing stores.
Oh, they explode.
So they're more annoying.
You got to hit him in the face.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me?
No.
Are you kidding?
No, I'm not joking around.
It is indeed a thing.
I can't tell if I'm hitting him or not.
Maybe I was.
This is the thing that exploded last time, right?
Yeah.
Beautiful.
Cover girl.
Give me the stupid sample.
Oh my god.
This is the stupidest sample ever.
What's the sample?
I like using the high impact grenade on them.
This pure...
They died in one hit.
10 minutes remaining already?
Yeah, this is a fast mission.
You just got to run.
I haven't found it yet.
Oh, I found one.
There's one there.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I found some hoes.
I'm putting down an eagle.
Did not come in here.
Oh, wait.
Putting down what?
I'm in somewhere.
Oh, okay.
I missed it.
There's a stalker.
He's invisible.
That's a stalker.
I got it.
Those are annoying stalkers.
Oh, no.
I thought the stalkers come on harder difficulties.
Oh, is that the invisible one?
Yeah.
We just need three holes and we're done.
Wait, is this one over here?
Yeah, you see the stalkers coming out over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see, I see, I see.
Wow, you're right.
One impact grenade really does kill them.
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
We're doing amazing, Mint.
I'm so sorry, Mint.
She's not sorry.
She's doing it on purpose.
It's because you haunt her at night.
Oh my god.
Wait, where is it?
Where is the hole?
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm right next to it.
I'm right next to it.
I'm trying.
Oh.
Got it.
Alright.
Can someone reinforce me?
Okay.
Yeah, it's like a big white guy.
He's really, really scary.
Guys, you cannot outrun.
They will chase you to the end of the fucking map.
Oh no.
They're like obsessed with that.
Oh my god.
Uh oh.
Hold on.
There we go.
I love impact grenades.
That's why I never want to switch them.
Oh man, I'm so far from my job.
Where?
We're just looking for...
Three more holes.
Yeah.
I clogged the first five.
Wait, no.
We need only one more.
Oh, yeah.
So we only need one more.
Oh, my bad.
Is that me?
Found something.
A sample.
How do you know what the combat is?
Oh, if you look at the map.
It's basically when you like get out of the map.
Ow.
Is when you leave the combat zone.
What's this?
Is this a sample?
Arthios, you just have to type exclamation mark mint.
Not mint.
Just exclamation mark mint.
Me.
That's me.
Yeah, that's her.
Oh, that's not a bug hole.
That's a...
A mint.
You got him, right, Haru?
Yeah, you got him.
A mint.
That's not me.
That's Henya.
You got him, Henya.
I'm age two.
She's age four.
Yeah, I'm age four.
Not age two.
Nothing to worry about.
No, I'm age two.
She's age four.
Yeah, she's age two and I'm age four.
Yeah, I'm age two and she's age four.
Wait, oh, is that why we're M1 and M2?
M1 reporting for duty.
Oh, I got a rare sample.
M1 and M3.
Yeah.
Oh, I see the other holes.
I see them.
I'm following you then.
M1.
M1 to M3, come with me.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Oh my god, there's three of them.
M1 to M3?
Yeah.
I'm going towards it.
I'm going to it.
No, don't go too close to it.
I sent a bomb.
Yeah.
Well, you could have said that like first night.
I said it.
No, you just said don't go close.
Well, I mean...
What do you think I would do when I first find the hole?
I don't know.
I would block it.
Uh oh.
Please let me out.
Let me out.
It's like the opposite of let me in.
Oh my god.
I'm going to die.
No, you won't.
You're going to live.
Oh my god.
You said I would live, you liar.
I lied.
Fuck.
I accidentally got...
I accidentally took your gun and I...
My gun?
Can you revive them, Henya?
Okay, okay, okay.
Hold on.
Yeah, I accidentally picked up a different gun and then I couldn't switch.
Help me.
Henya, no pressure.
Well, I already killed it.
Good girl.
I meant no pressure, like hurry up.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's a lot of bugs.
Oh gosh.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm going to die again.
Okay.
Don't die.
I was killed by nothing.
I just died.
That's what they all say.
Nice.
It just said killed by blank.
Oh, maybe that's a weird bug.
Killed by blank.
I don't think I've seen that before.
I've seen it a few times.
How did I miss?
Oh my god.
How could you miss that?
It was right in front of you.
How did you miss?
I have performance anxiety when everybody's looking.
I feel weird.
I felt that.
I'm getting deja vu.
You said this shit to me a month ago.
Which one?
That performance anxiety.
I told you everyone's watching you do the arrow game.
They're like, no, stop.
I have performance anxiety.
I do.
It's true.
Please turn the lights off.
I'm dead, by the way.
I thought you were already dead because you're a ghost and everything.
I'm so fine.
By the way, you should try not dying in this game so that you can do damage.
Yeah, that's a good plan.
I'll try that.
That's like a subtle diss.
I don't think it's subtle.
I don't think it's a subtle diss.
That was very subtle.
Where is the extraction?
Oh, I see the extraction.
Okay, let's run to the extraction.
I say let's run.
Meanwhile, you guys are already there.
She told me to run, but I was already there.
I'm on my way.
You're closer to me.
Friendship door.
Oh, friendship door.
Where are you?
I'm calling.
Baby can't see.
Did someone get my rare sample that I dropped?
I got them.
Don't worry.
I picked them up.
Okay, thank you.
I got you, bitch.
Thank you.
Do you want to do friendship with Haruka?
I've done it before.
Yeah, I meant that I've already done it.
Friendship ended with Haruka.
Everything ended with Haruka.
No, I've got it.
The friendship has been rekindled.
Okay, hit it.
They really did it.
Yeah!
And now I'll proceed to push you.
Oh, thanks.
What was that?
Guys, I don't know how to tell you this, but we should probably help Hanya.
Yeah, could you?
No.
I think Hanya's got this.
Guys!
Help!
I got you, Hanya.
I got you.
What's the big explosion?
Run.
I got you, baby girl.
I'm running.
No!
I came to your rescue.
M has come to...
The rescue.
Oh!
I tried to dodge, but I just did it silly.
It's okay.
One day you'll learn how to dodge.
And I'll be really proud.
I'm offense.
I'm not defense.
You know what they say.
Offense is the best defense.
Best defense!
Yeah!
Oh!
What the?
Where did he come from?
Where did he go?
Hanya killed me.
She's been married a long time ago.
Must be game glitch.
Oh, game glitch.
Game glitch.
Must be.
Ten seconds.
Let me in.
Don't leave without me.
Hi.
Let me in.
Preparing for touchdown.
Arriving at LZ.
So, Mint, every time I play with Zen, when we're all running into the ship, she just punches me as I'm about to run into the ship.
Every time.
Yep, she does that.
Every single time.
That's for Zen.
She what?
It's fine.
I deserve it.
Were you about to push somebody off the ship?
When you were telling that story?
Yes.
What about my story?
What did I do?
You were about to push somebody off the ship, weren't you?
When you were telling that story.
I deserved it.
I deserved it because I died.
What happened?
You deserved it because you died?
You only deserved it because you were about to do something.
Troll me, weren't you?
Troll me?
If I wanted to troll, I wouldn't explain.
Troll Kana Kahn?
Troll Kana.
Troll Tara Kahn.
Or as Hanya would say, Kuntaram.
Kuntaram.
Mint's like, stop.
You're ruining my whole sheet.
My channel.
All my streams get demonetized anyway.
All of them?
On YouTube?
For real?
A good bit have been recently, yeah.
What have you been saying?
What kind of shenanigans?
It's like a music stuff that happens.
So stupid.
Have you considered not playing copyrighted music?
No, it's because channels will upload music from games No, it's because channels will upload music from games and then even though they're not the actual owner of the music and then even though they're not the actual owner of the music and then they'll claim my videos.
Oh yeah, that happened.
I had that happen too.
One time I put like Bach.
I actually looked up classical like no copyright music and I got like 15 or something claims for that.
And I said no more.
You guys are getting BGM and nothing else.
Yeah, it's so awful.
It happens.
That's why I like to use video game music a lot.
You have to be careful because sometimes like what she just said that channels will...
Yeah.
Maybe because I stream on Twitch and I know that playing games with the BGM music seems fine.
That was my point saying if it's okay to play the game with the BGM then it should be okay.
That is really dumb.
It's silly.
It happens.
How do y'all feel about that being the last game?
You want more?
Because I've been streaming for 8 and a half hours and I have a big day tomorrow.
I also have to eat my lunch so I think that's a good time.
Yeah.
Lunch time.
What are you going to eat, Penia?
Sandwich today?
I don't know.
Maybe onigiri I guess.
Okay.
And you're not fucking sharing with the class.
What was it?
You're not going to share this with the class.
Yes.
No.
After all the deaths that we've died and all the people, all the books that we've killed and stuff.
You're not going to share it?
Okay.
I understand.
Have a nice day.
This is me posing with my Oshii.
Well let me just run through and ruin it.
Hey!
Stop ruining my picture!
Get out of my picture!
My photo!
My photo is not even!
I'm in the middle!
Me!
No!
She loves me.
You'll never have another You'll never have another hug again.
Anya, can I have one?
Gonna dance again.
I'm too slow.
That was so much fun though.
Yeah.
It was so nice to catch up again, Min.
Thank you for today.
Yeah.
I had a lot of fun.
I hope you learned a lot, Min.
If you ever want to play again, let us know.
You might now at least know how to play the game.
Yeah.
This game is really fun.
I like it a lot.
It was so nice to catch up with you, Min.
Yeah!
Let's play again soon.
I'm so down.
I want to play I forgot the name.
The zombie shooting one that we were talking about earlier.
Left 4 Dead?
Left 4 Dead 2.
Yeah!
I want to play that one too.
I'm so down for Left 4 Dead.
That was really fun.
That'll be fun.
We get all the mods.
I'm always around.
But if you also want to invite other people, I'm cool.
I got a busy time.
So keep me in mind.
Yeah.
Whatever.
I never think about you.
Okay.
We're recording tomorrow, I think.
In case you forgot about me.
We have to keep up the action.
Oh yeah.
You're right.
I hate you.
Yeah.
Bye guys!
Thanks for gaming!
Bye bye!
Have a good game!
Bye!
Good night!
See you later!
Bye bye!
Wow.
What?
Who's still here?
It's just me.
It's just us?
I usually like to be the person that opens the door for everyone to leave first.
I just didn't open Discord quickly enough.
No.
It's okay.
It was so nice to see you again, Min.
Yeah!
Let's play again soon.
Hell yeah.
I'll leave the door first.
You can hold the door this time.
Okay.
I'm holding it for you, madam.
Thank you.
I love you, Min.
Love you!
Bye bye!
By the way, you smell.
She ain't wrong.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Oh my gosh.
My brain is so...
I'm so tired.
Hello, madam.
If you see this message, that means that the gifted train has subsided.
I hope you're having fun gaming.
Oh my gosh.
I just realized.
Was there like...
Was there like notifications popping up the whole time?
Big Boss has become a member!
Welcome back!
You forgot to kill robots.
Oh, we didn't get to kill the robots.
Actually, I have no idea how many members...
Holy moly!
Why are there so many?
What the...
Like 20.
Why did there be so...
Why did the membership bomb?
Sorry if I was so bad at the game.
But, you know, first time playing.
But it was a lot of fun.
Matar was so helpful trying to like...
I mean, sometimes.
But there's like so much of the game that even I think if you like explain as much as you can, you are gonna forget something.
You know what I mean?
Like you're gonna...
You're gonna be like, oh, I forgot.
Oh, I should've... I should've talked about this or I should've mentioned this.
Who's this?
What a rush indeed.
You...
Yes, thank you.
Manage democracy...
Wait, to our enemies?
Wait a second.
What do you mean by that?
Welcome to the bridge, Helldiver.
Thank you.
La la la.
Wow.
This game is pretty though.
It's actually very pretty.
When I say that, I hope you're doing well.
I've not been able to super chat in a bit.
I wanna give you some money.
That's a-okay if you have not been able to super chat.
Please don't ever feel bad.
Okay?
Please, please, please.
What a cool way to watch you play Doom today.
Oh my gosh.
You know what?
I can see Doom guy in this a little bit.
Oh my gosh, look how cool- wait.
I'm trying to get a good angle like on the other- here we go.
Wait.
Stop, stop.
Like look how pretty.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get rid of all of us.
Even me.
It's so pretty.
I feel like a Doom collab with this game though would be perfect.
Like you have- Oh my gosh.
Can you imagine running from the Coco Demon and like um having like the guys and stuff.
That'd be awesome.
Actually I feel like- oh my god.
That would be so awesome.
This is a very Doom Eternal screenshot.
Hold on.
Actually I can be next to him.
What am I doing?
Stopping myself from...
Oh.
Uh...
I have to do this.
I don't know how tall- He said seven foot so...
How tall would I be next to someone who's seven foot?
Lower?
Lower.
Like here?
No.
I think like here.
Did you like the game?
Yes!
I had so much fun!
It's a lot.
It's definitely like...
What's the word?
It's not a game that I think I could play for like- I mean I played for four hours almost today but it's not a game I think I could do for so much just because it's like everything overload.
Like it's like there's this guy coming over here.
You know it's just a little bit of a battery overload in a bit of way but um...
You would be at his waist?
No I would not!
No I would not.
You guys I'm not that small.
Yeah it's a tense game for sure.
But it's so fun.
It's nice with friends.
Yeah!
I can see.
I think by myself I would be like um...
You know I would get a little I mean I already got overwhelmed but um...it's still a lot of fun.
Around the tummy and chest.
Wait, so...
Like this.
This is me.
Don't talk to me or my son ever again.
Let me also bring out my other arm.
I only have one arm up.
There we go.
Is it great today?
Just do image training of venom snake diving away from enemies.
Yeah!
That's the one thing.
It was the diving.
It's because it's alt.
I might rebind it to be honest.
To be like space or something.
Cause you don't use space for anything.
Right?
Not that I know of.
But it being alt just like messes up my fingers.
I put it on shift.
Oh, well you use it for climbing.
Unless you're running.
That's true.
Yes, yes.
Yeah.
Vaulting is space.
Then I'll figure it out.
I'll rebind it to something that isn't so...
I use extra mouse buttons.
That's a good idea too.
Like the side ones.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Mouse wheel for climbing?
What?
Really?
Is that normal?
Seems... I don't know if I like that.
I do dive more than vaulting.
That's true.
I need something that I can like click really quickly, you know?
To get up and dive and get up and dive and get up and dive.
This game has stealth?
What?
When you crawl?
That would make sense.
Cause there is crawling and stuff.
But yeah.
Hopefully you guys have fun watching our chaos.
We had a bit of friendly banter.
You know, like I said, just a big happy family blowing each other up.
You know, when she calls me a bitch, it's like... I know it's out of love.
When I shoot her in the head, it's out of love.
Thank you for the five gifts and thank you.
A lot of screaming.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
It's almost midnight for me.
You're pretty good.
Yeah, it was fun though.
It was lots of fun.
Would like to... Oh, I'm lagging.
Would like to play again sometime.
But tomorrow...
Tomorrow is sexy time.
Oh my gosh.
I can't wait to play the bunny girls.
I'm a big fan of curate games.
So, when I saw that this was coming out... Rather, when I saw that it came out, I was like, oh, I should definitely play it.
But then I saw it getting so popular and I was like, now I have even more reason to play it.
I love curate games though.
They're so awesome.
Time for limited monetization.
That's okay.
Did you ever play Dream C Club?
Oh my god.
When I saw this, I was like, this game is Dream C Club.
I saw... Oh my gosh.
It is so funny that you mentioned that.
I was like... Because, yes, I have played Dream C Club.
And I'm like, someone else... Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
I'm so...
I saw it... When I saw this game, I was just like, it's just Dream C Club.
But like... But, you know...
Oh my god.
Thank you.
That made my night.
Oh my gosh.
I played so much Dream C Club.
So, yes.
When I saw this game, I was very excited.
Yeah.
My reaction to Zoombini's... Yeah.
Me too though.
Me too.
But... I've played most of Maid of the Dead.
I think you'd have fun with that one too.
I do want to play that one too.
I want to play Maid of the Dead.
I know Trouble Days went popular... went kind of mainstream.
Mainstream?
Not mainstream.
It was popular amongst VTubers some time ago.
I was thinking of playing maybe Prison Princess because it's kind of like a hidden objects game, but not really.
It's like a point and click.
I don't know.
Curate Marathon.
Yeah.
This game really reminded me of Left 4 Dead though.
Really?
Doki Doki Literature Club.
I played that.
Just the VOD is...
privated.
It went Maidstream.
Speaking of Maids, I started watching Akiba Maid Wars.
I've been watching that.
I watched the first three episodes of that.
I've been watching the Konosuba anime season 3.
I've been watching Blue Archive.
Um...
So...
That show is wild.
Yeah!
It feels like...
Maids meets Kakegurui.
Or something like that.
Are you watching Dungeon Meshi?
No!
I want to start that one too though.
I want to start that one too.
Blue Archive Mahjong.
Let's go!
It's the only reason...
It's the only reason I'm playing so I can maybe pull...
Who all is in?
Actually, let me check.
I saw that Shiroko was in it.
Blue Archive Mahjong.
So...
Uh...
Brrrrrr...
Um...
Mutsuki Aru...
Shiroko, Hoshino, Aru, Mutsuki.
Just those four?
I like Hoshino.
I like Shiroko.
Do they talk in the game?
Like... Do you hear their VAs?
Ugh...
The Doki Doki Literature Club streams are my favorite, second to the Yomawari streams.
are my favorite, second to the Yomawari streams.
The Yomawari streams where I literally lose my brain, my mind.
I wonder if I've gotten better.
If I try and go back and play it now, if I...
Um...
If I'd be better.
I have Shiroko and Hoshino.
Nice!
My two!
I love the reaction when Hennia said she's serving her country.
You get more voice lines for them if you level up their bonding game.
You guys don't understand.
If Ogura Yui voices something, I either have to play it, I have to watch it, I have to do anything with it.
...
I'm always down for a redemption arc.
The Yomawari final boss fight.
It still haunts me to this day.
If you didn't know if a ghost could get haunted or not...
It haunts me to this day.
What's the first anime I watched?
It's hard to say because...
I watched anime before I knew of anime as a genre.
If you can call it that.
A medium, rather.
I watched Pokemon, Sailor Moon, and Dragon Ball.
A lot of those.
And then...
I think the first that I...
My sister's friend was like, Oh, do you watch anime?
And I was like, I don't know what that is.
And she showed me Inuyasha.
So...
And then from there I kind of watched Conan.
I got into Conan.
I got into Cowboy Bebop.
You know, I watched all those shows that were FLCL.
All the shows that were on Cartoon Network.
And...
My sister would show me shows too.
She showed me Elfen Lied.
I don't know why she showed that to me.
Why do I keep lagging?
I think the game is too beefy.
My Neuroquirk ReZero Season 3 airs in October.
Oh my gosh!
Yes, I also watched Cardcaptors!
I was cleaning... I moved some stuff around in my maid cafe recently.
And so...
When I was doing that, I was going through some old books.
And I found this old Cardcaptors book.
That I have had since I was a kid.
I even still have the Cloud Cards that I've had since I was a kid.
And like... it's just like...
Here's Sakura's friend, Madison!
So I watched that too.
I never... I don't think I ever watched Tokyo Mew Mew.
I watched a little bit of Sgt.
Frog.
Sgt.
Frog...
A mystic adventure, Cardcaptors!
Do you know Sora no Aozora?
From Denpugumi Inc.
Oh Nan...
I absolutely know Sora no Aozora.
She retired... No!
Nan, she's in another group!
It's called Arcana Project.
She left...
She left Denpugumi.
But she is now in Arcana Project.
So you can still listen to her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I watched a little bit of Hamtaro.
I think I only remember watching so much of Hamtaro...
You know, Hamtaro because of the You know, they always say like When they run around and stuff.
That's my first impression of Hennya.
What do you mean?
She's absolutely perfect.
She's my Oshi.
There's nothing else that I can say about her.
She's perfect.
She's a genius.
Everything that comes out of her mouth is gold.
It's genius.
She's her.
Yeah!
She is...
She is her!
Yeah.
My Oshi.
I'm starting to get tired though.
I'm starting to get tired.
I had a...
I've been busy cleaning and doing some other stuff.
So...
I should probably go to sleep.
Oh god, no.
I actually...
I can't stop yawning.
Thank you guys for hanging out with us.
I hope you had fun.
Hopefully it wasn't so chaotic.
Chaos craziness.
That
was so fun.
Thank you guys.
My brain is mush.
Mush, mush, mush.
We love chaos.
Tomorrow will be a little less chaos.
Sexy chaos.
Sexy chaos!
Just came from Henya's stream.
More collabs!
Thanks for dropping by!
Thank you!
I see.
Also recommend look up this video if you want to see her play Ace Combat 7.
She did PvP with one of the devs.
Thank you!
I will watch it.
I will.
She also really loves Gundam.
So...
Actually, I forgot to tell her the last...
Because the last time I saw her, I wanted to tell her to play Metal Gear.
I think she would really like Metal Gear, so I want to tell her to play it.
If she hasn't already.
It's not Mecha, but it's kind of...
I mean...
I mean, Ace Combat is not Mecha either.
But you know.
She's also like a Gundam ambassador though.
So she's so awesome.
She's so perfect.
She's so cute.
I love my Oshis.
The gift subs sure do clog up the dono notice.
They do.
Hahaha.
I don't think I can turn them...
I don't know if I can turn them off, to be honest.
But...
You know.
Yup.
Okie dokie.
I'm going to bed now.
Thank you guys!
Oh, I see your streamlabs, Riko.
Consider investing in the Laser Guard, Dog Rover, and the Mortar Sentry.
They make everything much easier by clearing a lot of the trash for you.
We'll look into it.
Thank you!
Oh, my chat just disconnected.
I wonder if there's a way that I can turn off.
Because, you know, we don't need to see every...
Oh!
Huh?
Uh oh.
Uh...
Wait, am I... I'm still stream...
Uh oh.
Thank you, Seymour!
Uh...
So...
I don't know if I can end the stream.
Because I don't remember my password.
Uh...
It's asking me to verify my account.
I don't remember my password.
Um...
Hmm...
Ah, hmm...
Wait...
Uh...
Their password was changed 21 days ago.
Deleting system...
Uh...
Um...
Forgot password.
Text means recovery number.
Oh, there it is.
Um, this is awkward, isn't it?
This sure is awkward.
Uh...
Oh, yeah, I can get the code.
Um...
Anyway... Um...
Would you, uh...
Um...
Would you guys eat for dinner?
If it's not dinner, would you eat for...
Um...
For breakfast?
Taco Bell...
Burger...
Chicken wing...
Beef...
Chicken, chicken, chicken...
Pizza...
It's not even Friday.
Okay, update password.
You can update your password now if you forgot it.
Save password.
Change password.
Oh wait, it just locked me out or just kicked me out of my...
Oh my god, wait.
This is so complicated.
Okay.
Save.
Thanks.
Okay.
What was I doing?
Oh, okay.
I was signing into YouTube.
To end my stream.
Hahaha.
I'm gonna end my stream now.
Thank you guys for...
Hanging out today.
And...
Hahaha.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for hanging out.
For, um...
Uh...
I hope you enjoyed the collab.
And, um...
Get some rest.
Good night.
Bye-bye.